Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
It's been a bit, guys.
Yes, it's been a while since I've been on Twitch, ever since the incident.
People never thought they'd see me back here, but here I am.
There was one thing, one company, one game that brought me back to Twitch.
Also, I did not realize it was my partner anniversary.
What fucking timing, guys.
So the reason why I am back here, I never thought, you know, it's been a while since I was last here.
But, I'll be here again for quite a bit, because I have a little partnership with Marvel Rivals.
And this partnership requires me to stream an X amount of hours per month of Marvel Rivals.
And because I have to do that, I've decided to do it on Twitch, because it's just easier.
It's just easier.
Whenever I have the time, I will be doing that.
Just be like, you know, just be like, whenever I do have some time for it, I'll be here on Twitch to stream some Marvel Rivals.
And that was the only reason why I'm back here on Twitch, because it's just much more convenient than streaming it on YouTube.
Because I don't like doing, like, super gorilla streams.
Also, like, when it comes to rank, I don't like streaming it on YouTube if it's like super gorilla stream.
Because, like, anything can happen in Marvel Rivals rank.
Also, I've not played Marvel Rivals in a bit, actually.
The last time I played Marvel Rivals was the 18th, so it has been a while.
It has been a while, so I am very rusty and I am on the main account.
If things do go bad, I'll be going on an alt account, because I do want to make sure I get the hours in.
But, I'm going to try not to make it too much of a long stream.
Yes, I know, it's very late.
It's very, very late.
Look, today was a little bit of a busy day.
I'll talk about this on YouTube as well.
I'll repeat this on YouTube.
But basically, I started the day off in this morning.
Finally, after four plus years, I have a family doctor.
You must be thinking, Yoki, what the fuck do you mean, four plus years?
Well, when I came back to Canada, I didn't have a family doctor anymore.
And then my parents sort of never tried to get me a family doctor.
So they would just be like, just get these off-the-counter medications.
You know, you'll get better.
I never had the chance to actually have a doctor doctor.
Also, where I live is, after COVID, it is incredibly hard to get a doctor, to be a patient.
If you don't have a family doctor before COVID, you are barely ever going to get a family doctor after COVID.
Because we have a shortage of doctors.
The doctor I went to today was a 20-minute Uber drive.
Because it was the only place that was taking new patients.
That was taking new clients, new patients as a family doctor.
Everywhere near me, walking distance, driving distance, was like, we're not taking walk-ins.
There's no doctors in Canada right now, where I live, that's taking walk-ins, by the way.
Like, nobody's taking that.
Like, you have to make an appointment to get a walk-in.
Which defeats the purpose of walk-ins.
Anyway, and even then, it's incredibly hard to do so.
Anyway, so, there's this specific website.
There's a specific website that tells you when a new clinic, whenever a clinic is accepting new patients.
And a couple of days ago, I was looking through that website.
Because I was like, you know what, I'm going to do it.
Like, my throat has been pretty messed up for a long time.
So, it has not been recovering for a while.
So, I'm going to do it.
And then, so, I looked at the list, and it was crazy.
There's so many, there's only three clinics in the entire area I'm in.
Within a 30-minute driving distance, there were only three clinics that was taking new patients.
I was looking, I was like, there's no fucking way.
And then, there was like this blog that was like, this clinic is now not even taking waiting lists.
And I was like, what the f- Like, there's some clinics that aren't even letting people add themselves on a waiting list.
They're like, their waiting lists have now closed.
And shit like that.
And I was like, Jesus fucking- It's a problem.
Anyway, so, today I finally got a family doctor.
It is a- I need to get my care card renewed as well.
Because I have to pay up front.
Because I haven't been to a doctor in four plus years.
My parents never renewed my care card for like ten plus years.
My care card has been expired for ten plus years.
So, like, I need to renew my care card too, as well.
So, my parents have never renewed it.
So, I have to deal with that as well.
And so, like, I have to pay up front.
I have to pay, like, a lot.
Because I- But then, like, the thing is, when I went to the doctor, she was like- She's a new doctor, by the way.
She literally got her- finished her trial- I don't remember what- I don't know doctor terms, but- She finished her, like, trials or whatever her, like, last year.
So, she's new new.
Yes, her residency.
She finished her residency last year.
So, she's new new.
So, that's why I was able to- That was the only way to, like, grab an actual family doctor.
Anyway, she was like- She, like, examined my chest, like, blood pressure, heart rate, throat.
And she was like, there's nothing wrong with you physically right now.
And I was like, but I've been- But she was just like, you've just been, like, back to back to back to back sick.
For too long.
Like, your throat is okay.
You've just been, like- You've just had, like, a really really rough time.
So, like, I can't really do anything.
Unless you want to get a blood test done.
And then, like, we can look over your blood test results and see how it goes.
And other than that, just get some vitamins in you.
And, like, maybe get a- Like, what's a Deflem spray and stuff.
And I was like, oh, is there anything you can prescribe?
And then she was like, no.
And I was like, no, not really.
You can get these off the counter stuff.
Okay, she was much more professional with the way she said it.
She said it a lot more professional.
But, like, how I interpret it was that she's just like, no.
And I said, is there anything you can prescribe so I can get better?
And she was like, not really, no.
Just gargle some saline water and maybe get Deflem spray and everything.
And then maybe you just need rest.
And you've just been back-to-back sick for so long that your throat just needs a lot.
And I was like, but I've been resting for a month plus now since the last time I got sick.
She's like, yeah, but you have been sick for more than half a year.
So you might need more time.
And I was like, okay.
Okay.
I don't know what else to do.
But, yeah, acts of Valentine.
Thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you, thank you.
So, yeah, it's just...
I'm gonna try and rest up a little bit, I guess.
You might look at my schedule.
It is a little bare.
I'm gonna try not to overdo it as always.
It's just my throat.
Like, basically, I'm just...
Sometimes I might still cough a little bit or my throat...
Like, it feels like my throat is like going through...
It feels like I'm going through puberty as a teenage boy.
But, like, it'll get there soon.
It'll be okay.
But, yes, I am streaming Marvel Rivals tonight.
But, anyway, yes, when I got back from the doctor.
Like, you know, my fucking 20-minute Uber ride back home.
I went...
I took a nap and, like, napped for, like, four plus hours.
So, I'm okay now.
I'm not as tired.
I am a little tired.
But, like, because I know I'm sort of a, like...
I know I'm playing Marvel Rivals.
So, I am a little tired.
But, other than that, I hope things will be okay.
FistfulVerbs, thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Not sure how much I can watch today's stream.
I hope the games are alright today.
Hope you feel better soon.
Thank you, I really appreciate it.
Thank you for the bitties.
White, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Zane, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
And Medi, thank you for the bitties.
Yes, so, yeah, I'm back.
I might try to revamp my Twitch thing a bit.
Because I haven't touched...
I haven't really touched my Twitch profile stuff.
So, it does look...
Like, it does look pretty...
Pretty old.
But, I'll think about...
I'll deal with that later.
Anyway, I'm going to do a quick play warm-up.
I haven't played...
I haven't played in...
Like I said, I haven't played in...
I think, like, almost a week now.
So, I definitely need...
I definitely need a warm-up a little bit.
If games get bad, I'm going on an ulti count.
I have a Celestial 1 ulti count.
So, I'm just going to go on there.
If things get really fucking bad.
But, yeah, it's my party anniversary.
Yippee!
Um...
But, to be fair, I feel like I've been...
Becoming more and more...
I'm going to play Syla.
I'm becoming more and more productive...
Over the course...
The last two weeks...
I've been so incredibly productive...
Compared to the last...
Two months.
It's actually crazy.
Although...
The doctor was like...
Because I was like...
What kind of vitamins should I get?
Um...
Should I get to help out?
Like, do you have anything specific?
And she was like...
Yeah, I'll get some zinc in you.
And vitamin C.
I already have...
I'm actually like...
Um...
Because my vitamin C is a Chihuahua.
But I did buy some zinc as well.
I think that's for like...
Blood, right?
I'm pretty sure.
Let me warm up with Syla.
A character I don't play in ranked.
Tired tonight?
I'm a little tired.
Now I realize why I'm tired so often.
Because, like...
I grew...
I literally grew up drinking caffeine.
Like...
I'm so fucked.
I'm finally...
Everything makes so much more sense now.
I literally grew up drinking fucking caffeine as a child.
And now I'm here.
I'm just gonna take the vitamins everyday.
That's really it.
Everything makes sense now.
Where are they?
I don't know if I should...
Oh my god.
I definitely needed to warm up.
Oh no!
Scarlet!
No!
My counter!
She can just left click me!
Holy shit!
Guys, I have no...
Guys, look.
Please understand.
I have not aimed at all for a long time.
Guys, I will admit that I do feel incredibly wired.
Gosh, right now.
I have not aimed in a long time.
This would be...
It's okay!
Oh my god.
I already feel...
I'm like, how do you...
How...
How do you aim?
Let me stand back here.
I don't know what I'm doing.
What?
No.
It's not fair.
How do you aim?
Aim how?
Work.
This is not fair.
Why they protect their support?
I don't even get that.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
I didn't see him.
Oh.
I feel so rusty.
Oh my god.
I might have to swap off Zylok.
No.
She's my best DPS character too.
If I can't even pull this off.
Oh my god.
I'm just gonna stay here.
Let me just tickle him from up here.
I'll just tickle him.
Let me just tickle him.
I know I am a tickle monster.
I'm too scared.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
I'm on your team.
I am the tick...
They call me...
Oh shit.
Okay.
They call me the tickler.
Cause I don't...
What?
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh shit.
No.
Okay.
Not fine.
Wait.
We have a disappear.
Nice.
Okay.
Wow.
Oh no.
That's not fair.
I literally just got here.
What?
And I'm the only one that dies?
Okay.
That's okay.
I know what to do.
This is my...
I'm worse on this character, but I know what to do.
I'm worse on this character, but it's okay.
Can't be that bad, right?
Oh my god.
My eyes...
You know...
I know when I'm like tired.
When my eyes...
Like, I can't focus my eyes right now and stuff.
When you're getting cross-eyed, that's when you sort of know that you're like tired.
That's like me right now.
I'm fucking cross-eyed right now.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
There we go.
Don't worry, I'm a hero.
Don't worry, I'm a fucking hero.
That's fucking right.
Hero time!
Oh my god, what am I doing?
I saw this in Marble Rivals Invitational.
I can be just as good, clearly.
Oh my god, I saw this in Marble Rivals Invitational.
I think I can do the same thing.
I think so.
It's okay.
I just poke.
I feel like I should be flanking, but like, I can't.
I don't...
Yeah, I do not trust myself.
You see, this is exactly why.
Guys.
This is exactly why I was not playing.
I don't think.
Oh my god, the fuck are you doing?
Crazy.
Where are you?
It's okay, I have my ult.
Guys, look!
I'm hitting shots!
Guys, look at that!
I am so fucking low HP.
Okay, look, I've seen this.
Oh, they saw me.
Fuck.
Okay, nevermind.
I guess I go down now.
Okay.
I'm doing it.
I'm doing it, guys.
I'm doing like point and click adventure.
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
Point and click adventure.
I'm doing it.
Oh my god, you're such a whore.
Nobody loves you.
If you're doing this in quick play, nobody fucking loves you.
Alright, see, this is how you die.
Okay, look at that.
I'm hitting buttons.
I'm doing it.
I'm just hitting.
Oh, I'm okay.
Don't.
Don't leave me alone.
Leave me alone.
Don't!
Please.
Leave me alone.
I'm not...
I have five kills.
Leave me...
All I do is farm damage.
Leave me the fuck alone.
All I do is just farm.
Just farm.
Oh, you're such a whore.
Jesus Christ.
Wait, there's none of them are pushing cart.
I mean, that's fine by me.
I'm okay with that.
Get this clones out.
All I do is...
Oh, fuck!
Oh, shit!
Okay, please, please, please.
Please, I'm missing shots.
Not her though.
Not him too.
Nice.
All right, there you go.
From five to eight, I'll take those.
I'll take those.
All right.
I'm glad my team is carrying me.
I'm just...
This is...
I think this is good aim practice right now.
I think like Hella is literally just point and click adventure.
Like anybody can be a good Hella.
And then you guys are gonna be like little assholes and be like, why aren't you anybody?
Anybody that's a DPS player can be a good Hella player.
I think she's like such an easy character to like learn.
Because it's literally just...
It's literally just you aim and then you hit him and then they're dead.
Like that's basically it.
Like if you can aim, you can play Hella.
What the fuck?
Okay.
If he's having fun, why?
Just let him have fun.
Great magic trick though.
I really enjoyed that magic trick that they did.
All right, nice.
Yay!
Let's go!
Oh shit, no shit.
Come on, point and click.
That should be everybody, right?
Who's still alive?
Yay!
Good job on that, Strange.
Okay, but try... look, I'm not TTK.
I think he's literally the only controller player that's like high E.
Like it's crazy that he can play like that with a controller.
Suddenly 14 kills.
Look at that!
Okay, I feel like I definitely wasted my time playing Psylocke.
I for sure wasted my time trying to play Psylocke.
Oh, my aim.
I'm not warmed up, guys.
My aim is still waking up.
Okay, we'll do one more.
We'll do one more game and then we'll go to the rank.
And then we'll get flamed, I guess.
We'll get flamed.
I can't wait.
I can't wait to get flamed, guys.
Let's try Psylocke again.
Maybe it'll be different.
Guys, it could be different, guys.
I'm slowly waking up, I am.
I'm very slowly waking up.
Guys, it's gonna be different this time.
I'm like more awake now, I swear to God.
I swear to God, it's gonna be so different.
I can do this.
I believe.
Guys, do you believe?
If I lose, it's because none of you guys believed in me.
Woo!
Okay, on this map.
It's fine.
I'll just play health pack.
I guess.
With Adam?
That's fine, guys.
Guys, I...
Guys, it'll still be fine.
I...
Oh, one of them left.
One of them actually...
They're like...
No.
Yeah, it's fine.
Everything will be fine.
It'll be okay.
They just...
They saw our lineup and was just like...
No.
Oh, and look.
We got two healers, at least.
Guys, it's getting that bad.
We got two.
Two guys.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Where am I?
Oh, I missed it.
I missed the die.
I missed the fucking...
Whoops.
Who the fuck doesn't break this?
Wait, that's crazy.
He didn't break that.
Oh, my God.
I can't fucking right-click anymore.
My aim.
Oh, my God.
I can't right-click.
Guys, it's okay.
I can left-click, guys.
I was distraction for my team.
It's okay.
I was distraction.
Guys, don't judge my right-click.
My left-click was really, really good, though.
Like, but...
What about my right-click, though?
Wait, my left-click.
Sorry, I can't...
I don't know my left and right.
My...
Okay, but like...
You gotta admit.
Oh, my God.
Oh, shit.
No!
I had to reload!
Oh, my God.
Sad.
It's okay.
I was distraction.
Look at that.
Every time I distracted, my team gets kills.
That's how I cope at night.
Every...
Guys, every time...
If you think about it.
Every time I died, my team gets 20 kills.
My death is like basically worth it.
Guys.
Jesus Christ, I almost missed that.
Look at that.
Each death gives us four kills.
You're welcome, team.
You're welcome.
Okay, can I get anything here?
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
Guys, it was not useless.
Like I said.
Every time I die.
And when I'm alive, we get kills.
Guys, I am helping.
Look how helpful I've been.
Look how helpful I am being.
Wow.
Where am I?
Oh, my God.
I'm so helpful.
Look at that.
Where did he go?
Oh, shit.
He missed.
See?
At least I didn't miss my ult.
Guys.
I didn't miss my ult.
It's the little things.
I'm so helpful.
It's the little things in life.
Guys.
It truly is.
Where's my team?
Let me just...
Let me not.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, my God.
Oh, eat him.
Oh, thank God.
Wait.
Okay, I was gonna say, but wait.
What about me?
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Where are they?
Guys, it's okay.
See?
Look at that.
Look, I'm doing it.
I am doing...
Oh, you think you can...
Oh, fuck.
Oh, get...
Did not expect to see a Venom here.
It's fine.
Oh, he already uses passive though, so I can do that.
Whoa, they don't know.
Oh, come on, please.
No!
Leave me alone!
Oh!
It's okay.
I'm still alive.
He left me alone.
It's okay.
I died because I needed...
I got Adamrez.
That's fucking right.
I'm back, bitch.
You might have killed me.
But I'm back.
That's fucking right.
Goodbye, Raccoon.
Oh, god.
Please.
Where is everybody?
Okay, nice.
What the fuck?
Who won that?
Look at that.
Everything came...
Everything worked out.
Look at that.
I'm not even bottom fragger!
Look at that!
Not even bottom fragger.
I did my job.
I got whatever the fire thing is.
I don't even know.
What is that?
What even is that?
I got quad kill.
Look at that.
He got five, but I got four.
Who needs...
Oh, my god.
You're right.
Who the fuck needs tank?
All we need is four DPS.
We're theorycrafting now.
Okay, I think I'm warmed up.
I think I'm warmed up now.
I'm not.
But, like, I think...
I think it's doable.
If we lose two games in a row, we swapping accounts.
I can't.
If we lose two games in a row, it's over.
We're going to...
We're traveling somewhere else.
All right.
0-4-2.
Exactly.
0-4-2 is the real meta.
Okay, I'm a little nervous because, like, it's been a while.
It's been a while.
I have a Celestial 1 alt account.
That we can use.
Like, I say we as in you're part of this, but...
It's our account, chat.
It's our account.
But I do have a Celestial 1 account.
And I hope...
And I'm pretty sure by the end of the stream, we're going to have a Celestial 3 account.
Without how I'm feeling tonight.
I am not feeling rivals.
I am not feeling, like, ready for rivals mentally.
And my hands do not feel like it.
But it's okay.
We can do this.
Why is Venom my menu character?
You know why.
You know exactly why.
He's, like, the best one out of all.
I think he...
Honestly, I'm pretty sure he has the...
He has the best ass out of all the characters.
Like, okay.
Here, I'll prove it.
Yeah, sure.
Yeah.
Yeah, she has that.
But look at...
But then you compare Venom.
And it's actually thicker.
It's actually...
It's actually, like, tall.
Like, you know.
It protrudes out more.
Oh, yeah!
I forgot!
Okay, so.
I have, like...
I have 43,000 currency.
Because I did promise you guys that...
That the moment...
I am sponsored or partnered with Marvel Rivals...
I shall spend for my first skin.
And...
Okay.
Not now.
But not now.
Not...
Not now.
We're in-game.
We will.
But not now.
Alright.
Who's on my team?
Oh, they fixed it!
They fixed it in the past.
You weren't able to see...
They're gonna run Hella Hawkeye Bucky?
Who's they?
Am I playing against some...
Who the fuck is they?
No.
Oh, no.
Who the fuck is they?
Who am I against?
The moment they say that...
They know we have someone.
Okay.
Am I about to get Glyph Armed?
Oh, I wanna ban...
I wanna ban Groot.
I don't wanna play against...
Oh, I don't wanna play against Groot.
I swear to God, if I get Name Ward or Groot...
I swear to fuck God.
I sw-
Okay.
I guess I suffer, I guess.
If like...
Do we have a shield tank?
Oh my God, we're all streamer mode.
Oh my God, I recognize this Raccoon.
I know who this Raccoon player is.
That's an insta boy.
I recognize that voice.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Story time.
This Raccoon player has the biggest fucking ego.
To be fair, majority of Raccoon players have the biggest fucking ego.
But this guy was like...
I had him like...
I had him once in my game and then I insta void him the next game.
But he was like...
He was like...
They're scared of me, so they ban my Rocket.
And I'm like, bro.
It's cause you can only fucking play Rocket.
They're not scared of you.
It's cause you can only play Rocket.
But...
I have to avoid this Raccoon.
I recognize that voice.
I recognize him.
Alright.
Oh my God, I guess I'll give this to group.
I took it, I took it, I took it.
Nice.
Nice, that's huge.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
But like, I cannot deal with Rocket players at all.
Hulk one, Hulk one, Hulk one, Hulk one.
Hulk Hulk Hulk.
I am not like...
I am...
I have Iron Fist and I'm like fucking wiener.
They don't have fight here, they don't have fight.
They have to play with Jax.
No targets, no targets.
I'm dead.
Fucking Iron Fist, man.
Oh man, unfortunate.
Oh, it's just me and you.
They have anti-dive.
Oh wait, we don't even...
We don't have...
Oh my God, he blocked.
Is this eating pizza?
Wait, no.
The eating pizza thing is not...
That's it, I can't tell.
There's too many...
All of us are streamer mode now.
Guys, first game is not always the best, guys.
We all...
We all know it.
Okay.
Guys, I don't know.
I don't...
I'm trying to believe in this team.
But like...
It's a little hard right now.
The first person that died was the Rocket, which is like...
Which is like...
The one person that shouldn't be the one that died first.
I'm surprised I didn't die.
Yo.
There are more people hiding around.
Okay.
Alright, what are we doing?
Guys.
We should just go like...
I am...
I'm gonna try...
To like...
Die, I guess.
Come on, bro.
Yo, yo.
Go Punisher.
Somebody go Punisher.
Okay.
See, this is how I should have died first, guys.
That's what I'm saying.
I should be the one dying first.
With like this comp.
Against this comp.
Yeah, I...
I'm not...
No, these are nobodies.
Like, I don't recognize these names.
It's also like incredibly late, too.
Nice.
Venom's literally one.
Get this Iron Fist, man.
Iron Fist?
Oh, shit.
Where?
Where is everybody?
Oh, that's...
Okay.
Also, I remember he complains a lot.
That's...
I remember now, guys.
This guy...
I remember now.
This guy also complains a lot.
That's why I...
That's why I also avoided him.
Alright.
Yeah.
I'm with you.
It's okay.
At least we capped first point, guys.
At least...
At least we capped first point.
I have no idea what's going on.
Everything is fucking too much stuff going on right now.
Everything...
There's too much stuff going on.
Alright, nice.
We did it.
I don't need to comm at all.
This team can comm for me.
Oh, yeah.
No, it is him.
I remember his name.
Alright.
It helps that he's like...
Has a...
Oh, shit.
Wait, guys.
I didn't freeze him, but I need to reload.
I need to reload.
Oh, it's okay.
Everybody is alive.
Oh.
I back away.
It's fine.
They used everything.
Alright, let's go.
Oh, wait.
Why did they ult there?
Because they said we push, so I push.
I was just listening to comms.
What?
I heard we push.
I listen.
Okay, let's go.
That's good because we didn't stagger.
Other than the fact that our...
Our...
Venom sort of...
Okay.
That's fine.
Everything is okay.
It's not okay, but...
Oh, my god.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's not okay.
We're so back.
We're not back.
I die here, 100%.
I am not living this.
I am not living it.
Who the fuck said push?
Somebody said push!
It's like, we push this.
I was like, okay.
I listen.
I only listen.
I just listen.
Okay, I'll never listen again, guys.
I'm never listening again.
Oh, I missed the freeze.
That's bad.
I missed the freeze.
That's so bad.
It literally is like, one thing.
If I miss the freeze, we die.
Yeah, we can walk it.
Okay, I have...
Okay, but what if it's our rocket that gets picked?
Do you think he would do it?
Guys?
Do you think he would swap?
Oh, fuck.
He fucking...
I did not expect him to do that.
Oh my god, I just got it.
I got you, I got you.
Oh my god.
There you go.
Nice.
Okay, what's going on?
What's going on?
What's...
All the timers.
What do you mean, please?
There's only two people alive.
It's Venom and Rocket.
These comms are pretty ass.
No, they are.
These comms are...
Oh man, I love first game.
I love...
Guys, I love first game, guys.
First game is always the most fun.
While he's playing Raccoon, he saw my Revival's Invitational and thought Rocket is meta now.
No, he's a Rocket one trick.
I've always avoided this guy.
I've always avoided him.
Whenever I see him.
It's not just because he's a Rocket.
Oh wait, he's playing...
Oh my god, he's playing...
I'd rather put him on Rocket.
He's better as Rocket.
I'd rather he plays Rocket.
Just because he's like his best character.
Alright, I put him on a character he's actually comfortable with.
Alright.
Yeah, true.
You don't need hands for Cloak and Dagger.
That is so true.
Okay, I'll put it on the Namor.
Alright, guys.
I'm not confident in this team.
But like, I'm just here for a good time.
I can tell I might die.
There is a chance where I could die.
Which is here.
Wait, why was he there?
Why is he playing Lone Drowned?
You say like, you got people on you or something.
Why was he...
What?
Why was...
Why was he on Lone Drowned?
Wait, what the fuck?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Why was he on Lone Drowned?
This is the first time I've seen a support on Lone Drowned.
First, to start off.
Please, you don't have to climb like Rocket.
You need to stop that vehicle.
You have to get the high ground as a support player.
And then, when things get rough.
Then, you get out of high...
Oh my god, I'm fucking...
I am not...
I am fumbling my spreeses.
I'm trying to heal.
Goodbye.
Okay, our Namor is alive.
As he's alive.
He's on off of...
He's off of Cloak.
That's...
That seems right, guys.
There we go.
That seems...
Alright, let's go.
What?
Oh my god.
Who...
Who called the bans?
Who set these bans?
Okay.
They gonna run...
Who is 11?
Who...
I'm gonna figure this out.
Who is...
I'm gonna...
Okay.
7.
Alright.
7 and 11.
Oh.
You shouldn't be allowed to type and talk in chat.
Dead first.
That's like
dead first on Rocket.
That's exactly what I said.
Like...
There's no way you should die first as Rocket.
As...
You're literally a raccoon.
You can climb.
What can I do?
All I can do is skate fast after 4 seconds.
Like...
Crazy.
That's what I said.
Okay.
Damn.
If we lose this one, we're fucking...
We're...
We're gonna get...
We're swapping accounts.
What a great start.
Okay.
Now...
Now, I can buy...
This would be the only skin I buy because I'm not a fan of all the...
Cause like...
I'm only buying skins of characters I actually play.
And I'm not a fan of any of these support skins.
This is the only skin I actually like.
But I'm also not equipping it yet.
Cause...
Unless they like fix...
Did they fix the bug?
Where anyone that had used...
Also, it's basically free for me.
I got the currency for free.
But did they fix the bug where if Loki gets MVP, everybody's OBS crashes?
Like...
Did they fix that?
Cause I don't know if they did.
Also, Ren!
Thank you for the Twitch Prime!
Thank you!
Squeaky!
Thank you for the Twitch Prime!
And Kelly!
Thank you for the Tier 1 sub!
Wait, you guys didn't know?
There was a bug where...
If President Loki gets an MVP, everybody's OBS crashes.
Um...
And I...
Like...
I don't know if they still...
If they...
Um...
If it's still going on.
But I will buy it.
No, fuck it.
I feel a lot.
Yeah, he crashes the economy!
I don't know!
I saw it on Twitter!
Shroud was talking about it!
I saw it on Twitter and it was like...
It was like talking about it.
Um...
On the clip.
So I was like, you know what?
I'll put it on.
Fuck it.
If it happens, it happens.
Wait, did I actually put my...
No, I didn't put it on.
Yeah.
Wait, I won't get...
Hey, you don't know that.
You don't know that.
My Loki's pretty alright.
I figured it out.
I figured out how to play...
Okay, I have not figured it out.
I've not actually figured out how to play Loki.
But like...
It can't be that bad.
I can do it.
I can pull it off.
I...
I can pull it off, guys.
I believe.
That's crazy, though.
I mean, that's how I feel on the inside, but it would never happen.
You're literally the trash panda!
Oh my god.
Please don't talk to me.
It shouldn't be allowed to type or talk in chat.
Jesus Christ.
It's like you have lost your privilege to talk when you pick Rocket.
Yeah, no, I 100% avoided him.
No, I've always avoided him.
Every time I get...
I see that person, I...
If he's on the enemy team, I avoid him.
I avoid majority of my Rocket players because I don't...
Like, I don't even do that to Jeff players because there's some really good Jeff players that I'm actually like...
I'm actually like afraid of because they can do like Jeff really, really well.
But like, I always avoid Rocket.
I always avoid 99% of Rocket players.
There's always like one tricks that I respect for like off meta characters.
I would never respect a Rocket one trick.
I know like there's a lot of one trick players that would force like, you know, they'll force Scarlet, Widow, Mr. Fantastic.
Or Penny or like, like all the like off meta picks, Squirrel Girl.
There's a really good Squirrel Girl top 500 player in rank that I respect a lot.
Because like, he's actually fucking insane.
Like, I...
You do not live.
Penny's incredibly bad in low elo.
But there is like one, one player on Penny that's really good and really fucking annoying.
But they're only good if they have another tank player.
Only good if they're not playing solo tank.
But I would never respect a...
I have no one on the top of my head with the amount of rank I played where I respect a...
Where I will respect a Rocket one trick.
I literally know zero Rocket one tricks that are good enough to be respected.
Jose, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope you met a...
I'm not, that's the thing.
I've never met a Rocket player that I respected.
At best, people would like...
People would just ban Rocket because that's the only character they play.
It's funny you guys, you think I respect Kony.
I'm joking.
I'm joking, I'm joking.
Okay, if they're playing...
Okay, I'll play Adam then.
I do Adam.
I can play Adam, I think.
It's been a while.
But like, I think I can pull it off.
Alright, who are they banning?
I tapped out, so I don't care as much.
Alright.
Groot, 100%.
I agree.
For real.
I'm glad we all came into it and understand.
I can't believe they fixed the thing where we can't see who we're with now.
Oh shit, no Luna.
That's alright.
It's too late, I've got Adam.
You can't steal it from me.
Well, we don't need to ban.
Let's ban Hela.
I don't mind.
There's no other character I wanna ban anyway.
What are they gonna ban?
Wolverine?
Why Wolverine?
There's no Groot to play anyway.
Alright, triple support.
Let's do it.
Our only damage is Iron Fist, but like, it can't be that bad, right?
Guys, do you think I would ever be able to like...
Let's see if we can adopt a player.
So we don't have to solo queue.
Just kidnap somebody.
So as long as...
If I have to lose Elo, I want...
I hope like...
So we can all lose Elo together.
Alright, I'm gonna kidnap somebody.
I do not...
This is very low damage for a team.
Our only damage is literally Iron Fist.
And like, I'm concerned.
I'm not going down.
Exactly.
I ain't going down alone.
If we lose this, we're swapping accounts.
But I ain't going down alone.
No, we don't need to take high ground as that.
Okay, not yet.
We'll take high ground later.
Guys, it's funny that you think I can DPS in my current state right now.
I'm not okay at the moment.
I'm like...
I'm way...
I'm way too like...
Lethargic right now.
Alright, Sing and Bucky.
Okay.
I am not...
They have an actual DPS character.
They have...
They have real DPS characters.
We have...
We have an Iron Fist.
Like, it's good.
It's just not good as a solo.
You know what I mean?
Like, not as a solo adventure type deal.
That's like what I'm like a little worried about.
Oh, and they have Storm.
Wait.
They actually have...
DPS.
Oh my gosh.
There you go.
That's fine.
Oh, our solo DPS is gone.
But that's okay.
That's...
Oh, shit!
Nice!
Okay, um...
We...
Okay.
Oh, he's kicking me out.
Oh, fuck!
Oh, I'm still here!
Okay.
Okay, I fly.
I fly.
Okay.
Okay, I'm...
I'm almost...
Almost have a...
Alright, nice.
Oh, fuck!
What the fuck?!
No!
What?!
Where did he...
Where did the Storm come from?!
He just let him walk over?!
He just...
Wait.
They just walked over!
Okay, it's not even pizza.
I have less fate in Iron Fist.
I'm just locked up!
Guys, I only trust one Iron Fist player and it's eating pizza.
So now I have less fate now.
Where is he?
Jesus.
I'm like...
Oh my gosh, my aim right now is as Iron...
As Adam is not like...
The most ideal IMO.
Oh, he's low.
Oh, he definitely has thing ult.
I am fucking scared.
I can tell.
I can...
I can 100...
What?
Already?
Jesus Christ.
There we go.
Okay.
That's a good Sol...
You have to admit...
He's still dead.
Okay.
I'm such a good Sol bot!
What the fuck?
That was such a good Sol bot too.
That's unlucky.
Hey look, we don't have Iron Fist anymore.
Thank God.
Alright.
I'm slowly walking over.
I am a slow guy.
The perfect being that travels...
0.1 mile per hour.
Perfection takes time, guys.
Perfection takes so much time.
Alright.
That's fine.
I...
Okay.
Guys, you have to know.
Perfection takes a lot.
There we go.
Okay.
I know he...
He still has his ult, but he's not using it.
It's a little concerning.
That he's not using it.
I'm scared.
Okay, I need to...
Okay, that's fine.
We ulted the other support ult.
I don't want to get too close because I have ult right now.
So I'm trying not to...
No, that's bad.
He's looking...
Okay, I don't know if...
Oh my God, I can't do anything.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
That's fine.
One more, one more.
I ult here.
Are you serious?!
Please!
Oh my God, I literally cannot!
I cannot!
I'm getting followed everywhere I go!
Please!
Let me live!
He follows me!
Like, what do I do when I get followed?!
Oh no.
Okay.
There we go.
No!
Why does no one go up?!
Guys, I don't think Adam's the pick right now.
I'm getting fucking hunted.
Like, crazy.
By everything in existence.
Everything wants to kill me.
Like, what do you do?
Oh shit, I don't have...
Oh my God!
Mantis?
We could.
We could go Mantis.
It feels like...
I feel like I might have...
I don't know.
I'm just getting hunted for res.
No matter what.
Okay.
Alright.
Maybe it's not me.
What do you mean he got banned?!
Wait, are they running free tank?
They are!
Wait.
There we go.
You're welcome.
I didn't realize.
Oh my God, they are!
No wonder they banned Wolves!
They're so smart!
Maybe I should run Mantis, actually.
They're gonna...
They're gonna run three tanks.
He just caught me here.
Exactly.
It's never my fault, guys.
We all know that.
Oh, he definitely has ult.
I can tell.
He's ready for the Kadabra attack.
Yep.
I'm with us.
There we go.
Oh my God.
Please.
Okay.
I swear to God, if...
I swear to God, leave me...
Fucker!
Okay.
I'm okay.
I'm...
I...
I can't do anything.
Every time I think about the potential to res, like...
They're like, fuck you, I guess.
I can't even think about it.
That's like the worst part.
Like...
It won't even let me think about the possibility.
Okay.
This is the first res I got to actually...
This is actually the first res I actually got put up.
Oh my God.
This is the first time I actually got to think of a res.
Okay.
Maybe...
I'm going...
Actually, no.
Atom is good because I have...
My E is good for this.
It's the one time where I have to use my E.
If I can make it.
Alright.
I'm just getting stuck!
Where do I go?!
Oh my God.
I can't believe they ran triple tank.
Alright.
Are they gonna go triple tank?
I'm going Mantis.
I ain't no DPS player.
Sorry, buddy.
Sorry.
I cannot play DPS in Eternity.
I'm sorry, buddy.
I put all my skill...
My pills...
Put all my points into...
Into support.
Sorry, Buckle.
You gotta live with this.
I'll play Mantis.
They're just heavily stalking me.
Anyways, Atom.
I literally can't do anything on Atom.
Like, every time I try to run anywhere...
They're just there.
Someone's gotta go Moon Knight.
I guess Moon Knight could work.
I just don't think we...
We just don't have the DPS players for it.
Yeah, no wonder they ban Wolverine.
You know what?
We'll counter it.
Squirrel Girl...
Squirrel Girl, Moon Knight.
We'll counter it.
Squirrel Girl, Moon Knight, Rocket Punisher maybe.
I'll just go Mantis.
I just don't think Atom is the play against Triple Tank.
It was...
We do not...
We should not go Iron Fist against...
What the fuck?
You see Triple Tank and you go Iron Fist?
Like, what's wrong with you?
Like...
What are you guys doing?
Tickle the other tanks?
Like, just punch them.
There we go.
Also, like, I wanted to go Mantis for the fact that I can sleep the...
I can sleep the...
See, this is exactly why you gotta swap up.
Oh no.
See, this is why.
I was like, what the fuck are you gonna do?
There we go.
That's the only reason why I wanted to go Mantis too.
I can't sleep though, right now.
Oh, guess I...
Oh, guess I die.
Why are you still Iron Fist?
Who are you gonna kill?
Oh my god.
Who would you kill?
You're just a little guy!
You just have kicks!
Let's give you this.
Oh, and then we... Oh my...
Okay.
At least we have... At least we have Hawkeye now.
Thank god.
I don't...
There we go.
I slept him.
Let's go.
There we go.
He has ult, so...
I can tell.
There we go!
Mantis...
Ah, Mantis 2 will work, I guess.
It'll work.
We did it, guys.
We figured it...
Oh, what?
I hope they're beating him up.
I... Okay, they are.
Okay, that's good.
They are beating him up.
Yeah, it's definitely more value.
Usually, Adam is the meta for triple support.
But, like, literally, they're running triple tank, so...
There's, like, nothing I could do as Adam with this comp.
It's fine.
I just don't think we should be running Iron Fist into this.
What?
How did that hit?
How did that not hit?
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
That should have hit.
That should have 100% hit.
Okay, I need to give you...
Goodbye.
That seems right.
Yeah.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
Bucky 1, Bucky 1, Bucky 1.
Oh my god.
Please.
Oh.
Live, Hulk!
He's not living, guys.
Guys, I don't think he's gonna live.
Yeah, I just don't think Fist is the way to go.
But, like...
Like I said, the only Iron Fist player I respect is...
Eating pizza.
I don't respect any other Iron Fist players.
Even if they're in Eternity, I just don't respect.
I mean...
I'm just gonna wait.
I don't wanna use it if they have Disappear.
Kiting, kiting, kiting.
Oh.
We gotta use this because you guys don't have use.
Come on, I don't wanna be the only one.
Oh, okay.
That's fine, I guess.
That's fine.
I don't know where everybody is, but that's okay.
Oh.
That's okay.
They used both ults.
There we go, guys.
Shoot him.
Wherever he is.
How did they...
Oh my god, there you are.
Go!
Go, Hawkeye, go!
You're more than I...
Clearly, you're Iron Fist.
Okay.
I need to farm you.
There you go.
Go.
Go, Hawkeye, go!
Let me farm that headshot.
Okay.
Go, Hawkeye, go!
Farm your shit!
Go, do your thing!
Okay.
Nice.
We're doing our thing.
I'm a little worried because I don't think that portal lasts the entire time.
So I think they're waiting right now.
Yep.
I knew it!
I fucking knew it!
I could tell!
Oh, he fucked it up!
Let's go.
I knew it, guys.
Like, it was so obvious that it definitely did not cover the entire time.
That was an awful...
What the fuck?!
Oh, there's a mag on point?
Guys?
Get out of here.
What the fuck?
Okay.
I'm surprised.
He's just chilling.
He's just chilling there.
Like, what are you doing?
Bro, he was just juking everything.
I was trying to punch him.
Bro, he was just chilling.
Alright.
Oh.
Well, first...
Don't worry, I got you!
Don't worry, Sue!
Okay, he lives.
That's fine.
That's okay!
That's okay, Sue!
I still fucking got you!
But who got me?!
That's okay.
Oh, no.
Oh, shit.
Oh, that is insane.
That is such a good ult.
Not gonna lie.
Wait, where?
Oh, there he is.
I'll just stay here.
I'll just push cart.
I think our team will be fine.
And I'll damage here.
And then I'll give you heals.
And then I'll also give you heals.
And then he's gonna slam in.
And then he's sleepy.
Sleep and we die.
We die.
Unless I stand behind here.
We live.
We had a strange in front of me.
I hope that...
Oh, my god.
Don't do it, son!
That's fine.
Oh, I'm trying to...
be okay.
Oh!
I can't tell what's going on!
What the fuck?
Jeff out of nowhere.
Talking...
Wait, is that...
Chopper?
Fucking stupid Chopper!
Oh, my god!
Bro, fuck you!
I swear to god, if that is Chopper...
Oh, my god!
I swear to god, if this is Chopper...
I'm gonna be so upset.
Okay.
It's fine.
Fuck this fight.
Fight!
Fucking hell!
Chopper's on his fucking...
Oh!
Fucking...
Bro!
Stunned five times.
That's right.
You deserve it.
I can't believe it!
I can't believe that's Chopper.
Was he the Venom player?
You come back!
I swear to god!
I'm so low.
Watch this Loki.
He sets up triple clones of everyone and then he just dies fast.
Oh, my god!
He's like...
Fuck!
I'll kidnap Chopper.
I'll kidnap Chopper!
Was he the Venom chat?
Was that him?
Was he on Venom?
Was that because I was sleeping Venom non-stop?
Oh, my god.
Oh, my god!
It was!
They fell for it!
They actually fell for it!
Oh, my god!
It is him!
No, they don't swap.
It's crazy.
No way!
In eternity?
No fucking way!
There he is.
Yeah, that was him.
That's why he's so...
That's funny.
That's actually funny.
I
slept him again!
He deserves it.
He fucking deserves it.
Oh,
I missed it.
Oh, my god.
Okay.
I don't think he got anybody, but that's...
What?
Oh, fuck.
Where am I?
Okay, there you go.
Oh, my god.
I can't believe it.
Goodbye, Chopper.
Goodbye.
It's crazy.
Don't worry, I'll try and kidnap Chopper.
I'll try and kidnap him.
Let's go, Donkey Kong.
There's only one player that calls me Donkey Kong.
Either we get a tie or we win.
We'll see how it goes.
Lucy, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you guys for all the happy partner anniversary.
Yeah, swapping your mantis was definitely the play.
Definitely the play.
We needed to sleep.
We definitely needed to sleep there.
The Venom couldn't do jack shit after that.
I'm happy.
I'm happy if we get a draw, because that was such a fucking rough game.
That game was so rough.
I can't believe this is real.
It started off so fucking rough.
Jeff is left side.
Jeff is left side, and then Loki is playing really far out.
We got this.
I'm okay.
Walk forward a little more.
They're coming, they're coming.
Oh, they did the thingy.
Oh, they pushed really far.
Oh, I missed a sleep?
Really?
Oh, he's smart.
He waited until I used it.
He waited until I used my sleep to go in.
Oh, I can't believe I missed it though.
He bad.
That's five.
There we go.
Nice.
Yay!
We did it!
He died.
He died!
We did it!
I'll friend him and see if I can kidnap him.
Guys, it's only 1am.
How are we at the point where all the Korean players are on now?
Oh, no.
Oh, yay!
I did it.
We didn't lose two in a row.
Let's fucking go.
Okay, where's...
Pottymonkey.
Why the fuck is his name Pottymonkey?
He might try to run, but let's kidnap him.
Okay, let's see if he adds me.
What?
I heard you were adopting.
I'm trying to kidnap...
I'm trying to kidnap Choppa.
Chop, if we could three stack with Choppa, we will be unstoppable.
No!
Oh, my God.
Oh, hey, sir.
Thank you.
Thanks, AZ.
Okay, invite me.
Okay, reach everyone and coach.
All right.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe it.
He didn't accept my friend request.
I failed my interviews.
He's on an alt called Pottymonkey.
Was that his account name?
Pottymonkey.
Yeah, Pottymonkey.
All right.
After that...
I can't believe it.
I can't believe he would...
Oh, shit.
Oh, he's in.
I got...
Oh, my God.
We got it.
I got the friend request.
Let's go.
Let's...
Oh, nice.
Oh, my God.
We're still in.
He live in this profile.
So, I don't know if he...
Okay.
I don't know if he's like...
If he's like in the...
God damn it.
I need to know if he's like already stacking or not.
I need to know.
I need to know if he's stacking or not.
Okay, queue up.
I'm not waiting.
I am not waiting.
Okay.
Are you...
Are you solo too?
We need to...
We need to kidnap him.
Twitchy, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
I need to know.
It's okay.
It's okay, guys.
We taught him a lesson.
Me.
We taught him a lesson he wouldn't forget.
By going...
Guys, I impressed a Korean pro.
Yes, but I am practicing.
Wanna join Gomez and I?
You can play all the Venom you want.
And there will be no man to sleep.
Fuck.
Yeah.
I don't think he liked...
I don't think he liked my man to sleep.
Okay.
Okay, we play one, two.
Alright, nice.
We got him.
We got Chopper.
Yeah.
Yeah, we do that.
Nice.
We did it.
We kidnapped Chopper.
Why he hating?
Cause I was on Mantis and all I did was every time he died me, I just...
Oh shit, he call me Shiva Gosu.
What if I ban Venom?
Oh my...
That's a huge compliment, guys.
That is a huge compliment.
A Korean pro call me Gosu.
That means really, really good.
I don't know about the Shiva part, but like...
Yippee.
I hope he doesn't lose this one.
Anyway, okay, we got our Loki skin.
Okay.
Yeah, she was definitely...
A great Korean word, but when they put Gosu and Shiva together, I don't know.
It sort of, you know, counteracts each other.
So I don't know.
I don't know.
Guys, I know what it means, guys.
I was in...
I played Overwatch 1, guys.
I encountered a lot.
I...
I was in an international school where like 60% of the student population were Korean students.
So like, I learned a lot, guys.
I learned a lot about the Korean ways.
I learned a lot of swears back then.
But yeah.
It's been fun, though.
I've been enjoying...
I've been enjoying a lot of just playing Rivalous today for you guys.
I remember why I stopped, because I was getting stream psyched really hard.
But maybe I'll be better, guys.
I'm on streamer mode now.
Maybe...
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait a minute.
What does NLE mean?
Wait.
What the...
I tapped...
I lurked away for...
What does NLE mean?
Is that an org?
What org is that?
Oh my god, there's two Doki birds.
Oh, is that...
That's Choppa.
That's the real Choppa.
That's...
The rapper.
Guys, when I posted that tweet about Choppa being Don King Kong, people thought it was the actual real rapper who said that.
And they were like, why are they saying the rapper is Korean?
But people did not realize that.
No, it's not the actual...
Oh shit, guys.
You can steal Sen Gomez.
Guys, do it right now.
Guys, make sure to get a name change right now and become Sen Gomez.
That's his fucking fault.
Guys, it's literally available right now, guys.
I wanna...
Guys, you can be Sen Gomez.
People will think you're the real one too.
Because they didn't realize he...
They didn't realize he changed his name.
That's his own fucking fault.
He could have done this to any other account.
Why the fuck did he use a Sen Gomez account?
Guys, sometimes identity theft is a joke.
Don't you wanna steal someone's identity for like, the rest of his life?
Yeah, I mean he could easily change it on his other account.
So true.
Sometimes.
Alright, Larry from HR.
I think Larry might need to speak to me after what I just said.
Master, thank you for the tier 1 sub.
Thank you, thank you.
Identity theft is fun.
True hero, thank you for the Twitch prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, he's gonna have to be like, Sen Gomez 1.
Or...
Right after.
Bro, he'll actually have to like...
He has to be... It's like Bo... Booger.
Booger's name is like Booger 2.
So like, they have to actually...
He has to not have the original...
He can't have the original name.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, we both have the same idea.
We both hate Groot.
We're all Groot haters.
Thank God.
Alright, I'm gonna go grab...
I'm gonna grab a new tissue box.
Oh, my tissues!
I don't mean myself, man.
Goodbye, more tissues later.
Alright, here we go.
We're Groot aunties together, thank God.
Yeah, I'm not gonna lie, this comp looks like...
Thank God we all hate the same.
My hate is unlimited.
Horrible.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, this comp looks a little better.
It doesn't look that bad.
It looks...
It looks a little better.
Thank God.
Sorta better.
Oh, are we defending or attacking?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
What do I...
Oh, okay, I can...
I can orb the hella.
Orb the hella.
Could be worse.
Oh, yeah.
Having...
When our Iron Fist finally swapped off of Iron Fist, the game suddenly got progressively easier.
That's crazy.
Doesn't Gomez have a fucking scrim soon?
Oh, guys, it's not my fault.
He literally was like...
I wanna play.
Like...
We all saw it.
We all saw...
It's not my fault.
I was solo queuing.
I was gonna kidnap Choppa.
Guys, I was gonna kidnap Choppa.
Okay, I was gonna say...
Guys, is...
Okay, I'm gonna say something really fucked up.
But, like, please note that it's a joke.
It was not my fault that Sentinels...
You can't say me.
It was not my fault.
I was streaming other shit.
I wasn't even playing Marvel Rivals.
They've been...
They didn't need my meddling to lose those games.
See, guys?
Look, it's all a joke though.
It's all...
Guys, it's all hee hee ha ha's.
Until it isn't.
It's fine.
Everything is okay.
This is such a dumb comp.
Not gonna lie.
Whoops.
Did not help that...
I missed my shots a little.
Okay.
But, no!
No!
I just got killed!
Okay.
That's good.
It's okay.
He can do the portal.
I believe.
I'll go first.
Where am I?
Oh, there I am.
Damage...
Okay, where?
Where?
Oh, I did it!
I don't know who I...
I couldn't tell who said that.
It's fine.
We did it.
Wait, what the fuck?
What is he doing in our spawn?
Okay, let's go.
Triple tank, let's go.
Triple tank, bro.
Let's go.
Oh, triple tank, bro.
Astor said it.
Okay, I don't know if we...
He's getting PTSD.
Triple tank PTSD.
You know what?
They should sign me on Set Hills.
We'll still lose.
But, like...
We'll have the more...
We'll have, like, at least a fun time.
You know?
It's true!
We'll have a fun time!
Like...
Like, isn't that what...
That's bet...
I mean, if we're gonna lose anyway, at least we'll have fun.
I...
Me?!
I was on a cliff!
Oh my god.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
It'll be funny.
Yeah.
Think of the content.
Right here.
Let me know when they're coming.
Oh, what are you gonna do?
Oh, they're doing the...
Doing the stranger.
Is that a good ult?
I got nobody!
Wait, he has my name!
Oh no, I was out of it.
No!
He did that with my name!
I look like the fool!
Okay, I didn't...
That is not a joke, guys.
It's not a joke, guys.
My reputation!
No!
Yeah, that's a dookie replay right there.
Alright, yeah.
Guys, I didn't...
That is not a joke, guys.
So, make sure you do plays like this...
When you're...
When you're Sen Gomez, guys.
Make sure it's just like that.
Jesus Christ, is he alive?
Oh, he is.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
It's okay, everything is okay.
I mean, he's gonna be okay, so I can...
Okay, nice.
He did it.
Can't believe dookie burned through.
Sh...
Guys!
That's not me!
I said that is not a joke, guys!
I'll ult first.
Just know that.
Oh, shit.
Guys, why are they all up here?
And we're all...
And then me and my Loki are down here.
Guys.
Why are they up here and then I'm up here?
And then I guess I have to do this.
Oh!
Oh, fuck!
Stop!
He doesn't know.
There we go.
The loop, the loop.
And we're all dead.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Okay, look.
I don't know how that happened.
How did I throw?
How?
Our Loki got...
There's nothing saving our Loki from getting fucking...
Like dinosaur extinction, dude.
Where the dinosaur is able to avoid a giant fucking rock?
I don't think so!
And dinosaurs are bigger!
Jesus Christ.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I'm behind you.
You wanna copy?
Guys, if the dinosaurs can't avoid the meteorite...
A person will not be...
Wait, there's a hellbine!
There's a hellbine!
Oh, and an invis.
Okay, I guess fuck me.
It was a skill issue.
They have strange...
Oh,
they're all here!
Okay, I guess I die.
It's okay.
I didn't wanna live.
That's fine.
That's okay, I don't think...
Alright, I...
I'm waiting.
Goodbye.
How did we know the dinosaurs didn't avoid...
Because we have fossils!
Where do you think they came from?
The fucking aliens planted dino bones?
They just flew away like birds.
Oh, he was trying to do the thing.
You fucking whore!
You're such a whore!
That would've been an insane freeze.
Why are we still on Thor after that?
Oh my god.
Guys, I was not throwing.
Okay.
They're killing.
Nice.
That's fine.
Oh, you can do this?
Okay.
Me dead?
Me not dead?
I guess.
I'll be dead.
Don't worry, I'll be dead here though.
Yep.
It's okay.
I'm not dead there, but I'll be dead here.
Guys, I don't think Thor was the play anymore.
For some reason, I felt like...
I felt like Thor might not have been it.
I have to go in so he can...
Okay, there you go.
Where?
Okay.
Okay, that's good.
I'm up here.
I'm out here.
Guys.
Now I feel like...
Now I'm not as...
Now I'm not as into the fact that...
My reputation might be...
Guys, it's not a Doki Bird play, guys.
It's not a Doki Bird play.
Such a huge carry fight.
You're right, you're right.
I did...
I did... Guys, that was crazy.
I hotboxed my PC so I can play both Strange, Hella, and Luna at the same time, guys.
It's actually crazy.
I know.
How do I do it?
Just...
You just gotta have it.
Dude, you can't learn that.
You just gotta have it, you know?
No, it's actually not cheating.
It's not cheating.
As long as I'm not throwing, it's not cheating.
If I was throwing, that's a different question.
But I am playing out of my fucking mind as two people right now.
See, we have to give this to her magic.
Alright,
we got this.
We just gotta push it all the way.
How bad can it be?
See, Larry, it was a good pick.
Don't enable him!
It was a good pick.
Okay.
Where's the other way?
How do we get out?
Just wait it out.
Oh, we gotta wait it out?
There's no extra door?
They did not think this...
How is there no extra door?
How did they not think this map through?
There should always be a third door.
It's fine.
Everything will be fine.
I don't feel fine anymore.
I still feel fine.
Everything will be fine.
I feel so healthy.
Don't worry, Larry from HR.
You'll be fine.
Oh my god.
They won't be fine though.
But it's okay.
I feel fine though.
I feel so healthy.
Oh my god.
No!
It's okay.
We have...
Loki.
It's just like Luna.
Yeah.
It's like three Lunas if you think about it.
Honestly, no.
Loki is actually like three Lunas.
Oh my gosh.
My...
I have a lot of deaths right now.
This is not good.
Alright.
Give it to the magic.
I'm healthy.
I feel so healthy right now.
My team is very healthy too.
Guys, you didn't see that.
Guys, my frames are dropping.
Guys, look.
I'm not very used to playing with less than 200 frames, guys.
You have to admit.
I'm playing with less than 200 frames.
So like...
That's why I'm missing shots.
Because I'm so used to playing with 200 plus frames.
That like...
It's not my fault.
Cool.
And I'm lagging too.
Yeah, yeah.
It just sucks so much, you know, when you're lagging too.
No?
Oh, please!
Thank you, Loki.
Oh, man.
That sucks though.
I can't believe I'm going through it.
So...
Fear.
Okay, that's fine.
We're fine.
We're so fine.
We're so...
We're still so fine.
Jesus Christ.
What is going on?
I don't know what's going on.
It's okay.
We did it.
See, guys?
We fucking...
Nothing to worry about.
Oh, nice.
Got her.
Guys, I'm just...
I'm lagging right now.
And like...
My ping is at 300 ping.
And I'm playing from Korea at the moment.
So...
I know it says 20 ping.
But like...
Okay, we made it.
We made it.
Guys, look.
I know it says 24.
But like, it's a visual bug.
Oh, man.
Don't you hate it when you get those visual bugs where it says 24, but you actually have 200 ping?
Damn, you fucking hate it when that shit happens.
Please.
Please kill him.
I don't know what's going on.
What's going on?
Are we winning?
Yeah, the sun's in my eyes.
I see it.
What the fuck?
I stood still.
I was like, what hit me?
A fucking squid inked there.
The panic ult.
That's right.
Oh my god.
Insane.
That's me.
He's talking about me.
Oh my god.
Alright, who got...
So, who got the Sen Gomez tag?
Did anyone get it?
Who got the tag?
That's my streamer.
Exactly.
That's me.
Right there.
Okay, let's see if Choppa's done.
Alright.
Invite.
Choppa's ready.
We might lose, but like, it's okay.
What elo is Choppa right now?
Let's see.
Wait, he's...
Oh wait, that's five.
Jesus Christ.
Choppa's 500?
That's not...
We're not playing with that Choppa though.
We're not playing with that Choppa.
Okay, he's 290.
Okay.
Okay, he's 290 now.
But he is forcing Venom.
He is forcing Venom.
So like...
He declined my...
Choppa, where are you?
Where did...
Where did Choppa go?
Did you lose?
Where did he go?
Oh my God.
I don't know if he lost or not.
His profile's private.
Imagine putting your career profile private.
I say, couldn't be me.
Hit him while he's down.
Alright, I'm fucking...
We're...
Okay.
I think like...
If you...
Okay, yeah.
There you go.
That's what you get.
Now you can't spam me.
Anytime.
Alright.
There you go.
We gotta...
Why the block?
Cause then they'll keep spamming it.
The only way...
They'll keep spamming it.
The only way to like...
Like, not deal with the...
Spam is just blocking them.
Guys, I'm trying to...
Guys, I'm trying to kidnap someone right now.
Legally kidnap them.
They consented, guys.
I'll show you the proof.
Guys.
They legally consented to getting kidnapped.
Where is it?
Yeah, see?
If you guys want...
Go invite.
There you go.
That was consensual right there.
Consensual kidnapping.
I believe you.
I don't need proof.
He didn't decline, chat.
He didn't willingly decline.
It's only because...
It's only because he's AFK, chat.
He's...
He's AFK right now.
And because he's AFK...
I can't accept him.
Like, he can't accept it.
Guys, he is not dodging the stack.
Guys, I swear to God.
Oh my God.
Choppa, where the fuck did you go?
Maybe...
Maybe he's crying because he lost.
I don't know.
He could be.
Invite.
Choppa, please.
Choppa.
Oh, there he is.
He's back.
Choppa here.
Q.
Donkey Kong, man.
Alright.
Did you win?
Or did...
Did you win, Choppa?
Where the fuck did...
Yo.
The triple, the double.
I'm a man.
What the fuck does that mean?
Doesn't like NLG.
But you are NLG, Choppa.
Why are you...
Nah.
But you lost to me.
Oh my God.
Unlucky one time.
Whatever.
Wait.
I saw five all sleep.
Man of man.
For you too.
But I'm a...
Nah, I need one clip for you, man.
Wow, Choppa's so generous, guys.
Guys, he's so generous.
He fucking got me clips.
He lost so I can...
I can get clips.
Oh, okay, okay.
Group bug.
Okay.
We invite again.
And then...
There we go.
He's so generous.
Oh my God.
So...
So nice of him to like...
Make sure that I win.
So I can...
Oh, no, it's still bug.
Why are you bad at this?
I believe...
I am joking.
Identity theft is not a joke.
Okay.
There you go.
Yeah!
We did it.
We're alive now.
How are you?
500 points.
If you are better than...
Don't Google me.
Okay, potty.
Who's potty monkey?
Okay.
Is that act?
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
Okay, it's not.
Okay.
Your time.
You don't exist.
Are you sure?
You are famous?
Of course.
Are you lying?
Do we have any JP people in chat right now?
Have you...
Do you guys...
Do you guys know who potty monkey is?
Yo, just...
Google it.
Guys.
Do you have any JP citizens?
In my chat?
Anyone in Japan?
He is a man.
A man.
The famous potty monkey.
Just Google man.
Yo, yo.
Not chat.
Just Google.
Potty monkey is potty monkey.
I am not JP, but I can confirm.
I don't know him.
I found potty monkey.
What?
Wait, he's not even JP.
It's...
It's Korean.
It's still Korean.
Wait, there is a potty monkey song.
What the fuck?
Wait.
There is a potty monkey song.
Oh my god.
There it is.
Wait.
You are famous.
You are...
But...
Potty monkey is Korean.
What?
YouTube potty monkey.
He is the potty monkey.
Oh my god, he is real.
We are gonna boost the viewership.
Oh my god, we are playing with the potty monkey.
You are too bad.
You are not as good.
Good as Chopper.
Only 200 points.
Are you sure he is real?
Yeah, he plays in NA servers with this ping.
I didn't even see what the song was about.
I was like, wait, there is a Korean song called potty monkey.
I can't believe it, he was real.
He was not shitposting.
Haha, pun not intended.
Alright.
Wanna bar or what?
The fuck does that mean?
What the fuck?
I don't know what's wrong with him, I'm sorry.
He only has 15k more listeners than me.
Okay, I'm banning Groot, I don't fucking care.
I don't care, I'm not letting potty monkey play Groot.
I'm not letting him play Groot.
You said he is playing Venom?
Fucking let him play Venom.
Okay, nice.
Alright, that's fine.
Is this considered throwing?
Guys, you don't understand, we have the potty monkey on my team.
How could we lose?
How could we?
I hate Groot more.
I hate Groot more in rank.
Cause like...
Cause like, even we have a rocket one trick, it's still sort of winnable.
But like, having a better Groot player on the enemy team is just like, not it.
Why we have...
I'm that good.
Playing on two PCs.
Hahaha.
Yo, you AI.
I'm just that crack.
I'm very advanced.
Technically I am if you think about it.
If you think about it, I'm technically a very advanced form of AI.
Don't worry, he'll be fine.
I believe in potty monkey.
Number one JP Korean rapper.
What?
I was not living that.
Oh, hello.
Oh, fuck.
I am not living that.
Oh, my god.
I'm alive?
Somehow?
I don't know how.
I'm a little scared though.
Where is he?
Oh, my god.
No.
Please.
It's time.
Guys, we all know what this means.
I'm ready to pull out the mantis soon.
There's like four different fights.
There is.
Oh, my god.
No, there was four different fights going on.
I was like, what the fuck am I?
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
Goodbye.
Yeah, yeah, damage.
I'm damaged.
Okay.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh, no.
That's where I die.
I'm coming back.
Oh, shit.
Fear god.
Why the fuck is there a partymonkey.com?
Oh, goodbye.
Oh, please.
I will go mantis.
I'm going mantis.
I will go mantis if I have to.
I will go mantis.
I know what to do.
It's okay.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
I'm gonna do that thing I did.
Okay.
It's fine.
What the fuck is this?
What is this?
What does this say?
Oh, shit.
Oh, my god.
Fuck.
I didn't know where to go.
I was just getting harassed all day.
What is... I don't know.
I don't know what he's saying.
Okay, I wait.
I wait.
Oh, my god.
See?
This is how you rocket one trick.
Okay, to be fair, what we had before, that other guy, the deleted guy getting...
Our rocket actually going through hell, living through everything possible.
That's crazy.
Versus like...
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
He actually got me.
But no, it's okay.
I'm alive.
That's fine.
Oh, my god.
He actually flew away.
That's crazy.
Who's gonna save him?
Cause it's definitely not me.
I need someone to save me first.
Oh, my god.
Okay.
I'll go Luna again after this.
This is unlucky.
Okay.
I go back to...
I go back to Luna.
LOL.
Surely, it won't be as bad now.
Right?
Guys, I go back to Luna.
It won't be as bad, right?
We just lost both supports?
Question mark.
No, we did.
We did.
Okay.
That's good.
There we go.
It's fine.
It's so fine.
It's not, but like, you know, I like to cope sometimes.
Oh.
No.
Choppa.
There we go.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, shit.
Okay, there was a lot...
There's a lot of stuff going on on my screen and I don't know who's who.
There's a lot of stuff on my screen and I'm getting very confused.
Oh, I missed.
I missed.
That's fine.
Okay.
It's okay.
It's not, but like, we used a lot for zero kills.
So...
That's good.
That's...
Oh, no.
I'm on the thing.
Please.
Oh, please.
No!
I'm 2%!
No, and I didn't get...
Oh, no.
I'm on it.
I'm fucking on it.
I dance.
I die, but I dance.
I...
I die, but...
I dance.
Oh, I definitely die here.
What?
Oh, man.
I definitely die here.
Oh!
Fuck you!
Why don't you have a kill?
One kill!
Please!
Oh, my god!
It's okay.
Things could be okay.
Oh, my god.
I don't...
Please!
Why is he still there?
Oh, my...
I'm alive.
Oh, please.
Oh, I'm alive!
Somehow!
Nice.
This is where I die, too.
Goodbye!
Hello?
I think...
How?
Holy shit!
He's on killable!
Oh, my god!
Why couldn't he do that when he was...
He's actually...
Why couldn't he do that before?
Why couldn't he?
Oh, my god!
I've been struggling so hard!
He's Japanese.
Oh, my god!
He does not represent...
Guys!
Guys, this is...
He's Chopper, guys.
He does not represent our group.
He does not represent our group, guys.
He does not represent my views, guys.
Oh, my god!
Chopper...
He got a potty mouth.
Guys, please don't cancel me.
It's not my...
Please don't cancel me, guys.
Please.
I hate...
Why couldn't he do this?
Guys, we just gotta go triple team.
The last time...
He couldn't do anything when he was on triple team, guys.
That's the key.
He literally couldn't do jack shit on triple.
Wait.
What?
Did he just lag there?
Like, what the fuck was that?
What the fuck?
What happened to him?
Iron Fist left.
Iron Fist behind us.
Oh, my god.
How?
He got shielded from back there?
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
He actually got, like...
Shielded all the way from back there, like...
Oh.
He potty monkey alive.
That was, like, actually to nowhere.
Not nowhere.
I was setting that.
It's okay.
He's alive.
Why follow me?
Alright.
That's fine.
I'm damage boosting this.
It's okay.
It's not okay, but it's okay.
Let me get rid of this.
Oh, my god.
Where am I?
He waited for me.
Why couldn't he do that when he...
Oh, because they were on triple tank.
They were on triple tank.
That's why.
That's why he couldn't do anything.
I remember now.
He was useless on Iron Fist.
When there was triple tank.
Guys, I remember.
Guys, I remember now.
Jesus Christ.
I...
Okay.
I froze him.
What more do you want from me?
I did everything I was supposed to do with my job.
I don't have another freeze.
Only 60 seconds left.
I get one.
Guys, I think...
I think PartyMouth is gonna lose.
I have ult.
I think he might...
Okay, I missed the freeze.
Look, I cannot hit every freeze, guys.
He's looking.
Oh, my god.
Please.
That was insane.
That was a really good damage boost.
There we go.
Did they live?
Did the Venom live?
Chopper.
NLE Chopper.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
I can't stay.
I'm not focusing.
Oh, my god.
I don't know.
Fuck.
Oh, my god.
We're okay.
Now he's dead.
Holy shit.
Chopper's fucking wild.
Oh, my god.
Did not realize he's so wild.
He's so fucking wild, guys.
Jesus Christ.
He is an animal.
He is a fucking animal.
Oh, my god.
Please.
Are we dancing?
I'm not.
Oh, my god.
He just beat the shit out of me.
That's so fucked up.
He literally just beat the shit out of me.
What do I do?
Oh, my god.
I had Iron Fist and Venom just pummeling me.
Like, what do I do in that situation?
I just die?
Yeah, I guess I do.
Oh, my god.
No!
He
killed us through everything.
He killed us through everything.
What happened?
Oh, my god.
He actually killed us through everything.
That's crazy.
Oh, I had a feeling.
I... Oh, my...
Oh, my god.
I don't know how I got that fucking freeze in, but I take those.
I take those.
Oh, I missed the freeze, though.
That's not good.
Nice.
What's going on?
I'll never know.
Oh, fuck.
Guys, I don't know.
Things ain't looking so good for us.
I don't know.
Things are...
Things are looking pretty rough.
I'm a little scared.
Oh, my god.
I'm so scared.
Oh, this is where he's gonna beat me up.
He's gonna...
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Oh, my god.
This is good.
Our damage boost.
Oh, I leave.
I leave.
I'm fine, thank you.
Guys, do you think he's fine?
He said he's fine.
He's like, I'm fine, thank you.
No!
Good for you.
Good for you, Chapa.
Guys, I was not having a great game there.
I was fucking getting pummeled non-stop.
Like, I was...
I was getting pummeled non-stop.
I was getting... Wait.
Venom.
Venom tip.
Chapa would never lose that.
Did you avoid DPS?
He is honest.
Okay, nice.
DPS avoided.
Yeah, our other DPS was not having a good time too.
He had more... Surprisingly, he had more deaths than me.
Which is very surprising because I was having a really rough time as Mantis and Luna.
Like, I had to go Mantis first because I was literally, like, having a rough time.
Because I was not getting any peeled at all.
So I was trying to see if I could just sleep them.
But then...
But then, things did not...
And then I swapped to Luna because I was like, okay, maybe...
Maybe I can make it work.
Maybe.
Maybe I can make it work, guys.
Yeah, our Winter Soldier was not having a good time.
Oh, Suta!
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you!
I didn't know it was your raid earlier, but thank you!
I was having a really rough time earlier.
With, like, 200 people trying to kill me.
And then I got Strange Ulted.
I got Venom Ulted.
I ulted and I still died through my ult.
Nothing was okay.
Nothing was okay for me.
I was just meant to die, I think.
But yes, thank you for the raid!
For those who don't know me, my name is DokiVirid.
I usually stream on YouTube, so please check me out on YouTube.
But I have a recent partnership with Marble Rivals.
And that requires me to stream an X amount of hours per month for Marble Rivals.
So that's why I'm doing it here on Twitch now.
Just to make sure I meet the quota that I need to do for each month.
But yes, hello!
Welcome, everybody!
I am playing Marble Rivals Ranked with NLE Choppa and Super Gomez right now.
For those who don't know, they are actually really, really good players.
They were willing to get kidnapped by me.
To play ranked.
For those who don't know what their mains are.
So this is Choppa.
He is literally 502 points right now.
And then, Gomez's main is 426.
And I'm just, I guess, a baby.
I'm a baby.
I only have 326 points.
Just not that much compared to everybody else.
I'm just a little baby.
Wait, what is the rank number right now?
Oh shit, he is ranked 4?!
Oh my god!
Wait, I'm playing with the ranked guys.
New clickbait title.
Playing with the ranked 4 player.
With top 5 player.
Playing with the top 5 player right now.
That's my clickbait title.
Let's go, clickbait.
Yeah!
Bottle, thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
I want to credit Ashley and you on your sportsmanship at the Twitch Rivals MR.
You were great.
Despite everything you went through, you managed to win.
My compliments again.
Have a great stream.
I have to go to work.
Thank you!
Thank you for the bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
No, that's not my friends list.
No, look here.
Oh wait, that is my friends list.
JK.
Oh my god.
Sorry, I'm dumb.
Alright, what is he?
I'll never know.
Top 30 guys.
Wait, is that 600?
That's like crazy.
Are we playing with the same people and against the same people?
We have to be because...
I would not be surprised if we're playing with and against the same people.
I can't fish myself.
I think I'm playing against the Sinatraa 3-stack.
Because we're 3-stacking now too.
So it makes sense that we're playing against the same 3-stack.
Unless they finished?
I don't know.
Maybe they stopped playing.
I gaslighted myself into clickbaiting.
Wolverine?
Okay.
Ah!
No, trio tank.
Triple tank.
Oh shit!
Triple tank!
Okay.
I play Bucky.
Ben... Adam?
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Triple tank time.
Yo, check me out this mag.
This mag.
What?!
It's triple.
Wait, what?
We got two Japanese.
Never lose.
Oh my god.
Chopper.
Wait, go Mantis?
We can do one tap.
I mean like, we can play 3 tanks, right?
Oh my god.
Yeah, yellow hair, yellow hair.
Chopper, triple tank, chopper.
Alright, what?
Triple tank, 3 tank, 3 tank.
Who is a chopper?
A Venom?
Fuck you!
Triple tank, triple tank, triple tank.
What should I do?
Tank, tank.
Take me, take me, take me, take me.
Let's go.
Okay.
You are Venom and he's a chopper?
Hair.
Shut up.
Oh my god, chopper.
Okay, do we have lucky?
Okay, lucky mag.
Guys.
Hello, lucky hello.
I gave you ammo, I gave you ammo.
I have bubble, I have bubble.
Go push, go push.
Van line low, van line low.
Wait, Sylas one.
Sylas low, Sylas low.
Oh, Venom.
I'll keep my gun, I'll keep my gun.
Yo, chopper, something good, what the fuck are you doing?
I have bubble, I have bubble, I have bubble.
What's going on?
Mag, mag, mag, mag, mag.
Oh my god.
What's going on?
Hey, right side, suit, suit, suit, suit, suit.
What the fuck is going on?
I killed body, body.
Yo, chopper, something good, oh.
Bubble you, bubble you.
Oh, Sylas got me, Sylas got me.
I'm put.
Sylas, Sylas, Sylas.
Behind someone, behind someone.
Sylas one.
I got him, yeah.
Are you okay?
Yeah, yeah, I'm okay, I'm okay.
Oh my god, he's so polite.
What the fuck?
Oh, shield.
Shield, no!
Where's shield?
Chopper, where's shield?
One, one, one, one.
Okay, okay.
Hello, chopper.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
I'm fucked up.
I can damage you.
I'm back, I'm back, I'm back.
We can Luna, Luna.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, Hala main, Hala main.
Okay.
There's a Sylas on point.
Sylas behind guys.
Okay.
I'm pushing main.
Three, two, one.
Hala, Hala, Hala.
Oh my god.
Mag on me.
Go up, go up.
Mag one, mag one.
No!
There's a Sylas.
Oh, I'm alive.
Yippee!
Sylas one, Sylas one.
Let's go guys.
Okay, everything is okay guys.
Everything is as okay as it can be.
Before it starts not being okay.
It's as okay as it can be until it's not okay.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Everything is okay until it's not okay.
Okay.
Focus Hala.
I can't!
No!
You're down too.
I'm five percent.
Can I blow up?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'm damaged.
Oh, Rocket's dead.
Rocket's dead, I get it.
Come back, come back, come back.
Oh,
goodbye.
I was like, well, at least Rocket's dead.
I believe.
Let's go.
Wait, four take?!
I can't get through portal.
No!
The portal!
I couldn't get through portal!
No!
No heals, yeah.
No more Rocket, no more Rocket, please.
What's up?
He swapped.
I'm on D, Hala.
Yeah, I've been off.
Okay.
One, next, five, take.
Guys, I can solo this.
That's fine.
We can go, we can go.
We'll come down.
I hear Psylocke behind us.
No, no, no, we'll come down.
Yep.
Psylocke behind.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Go push, guys, I'm on it.
No!
Oh, he double super ulted.
I'm damage boosting, I'm damage boosting.
You're damage boosting!
Rocket one, Rocket's one!
Nice.
Okay, nice, nice.
That's fine.
We stacked, but it's okay.
It's okay.
We still made it.
Things still worked out.
Oh my god.
Lynn!
Lynn, thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you, I really appreciate it.
Also, Flynn, thank you for the Twitch bombs.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, what did he say, guys?
What did he say?
Is it appropriate?
I just know...
What did you say?
No, I am going my phone.
Okay.
You're having a normal conversation.
I only think to read this.
I don't trust Chopper anymore.
I don't trust him.
I'm reading it.
You guys are saying...
You guys are confused.
What?
Wait, you lied on the internet?
Change topic?
I don't know.
What do I do?
What do we do?
What do you mean you don't know?
I don't know.
I'm going left.
What is this?
I'm dead.
Too many things.
Oh my god.
I'm scared.
Why?
Why did you bring him closer to us?
Please.
I can't keep us up any longer.
Oh my god.
Why did you...
That is unfortunate.
I don't know how to live.
That is...
That is unfortunate.
I go first?
Okay.
We got this.
He jumped into the mega.
That was crazy.
He was...
He was fucking wild.
Fucking wild.
Oh my god.
I can't go any...
Oh, hello.
Hello.
I'm coming back.
Please.
Someone get the Hella, please.
In the sky.
No.
The Hella just shot us for free.
Oh, did he shoot us for free?
Okay, I'm here now.
It's okay.
Okay.
Let me try.
Jesus Christ, we can't see the tanks.
We're getting pushed back so hard.
Is it winnable?
No.
Not winnable.
I'm getting harassed so hard.
I'm getting harassed right now.
Why am I always getting harassed?
They use megas.
How do I position myself when there's...
When this fucker keeps trying...
It's not fair.
She can just go invisible.
What can I do about that?
Heal tank.
Mega one.
Mega is really one.
Oh, really?
He's really one.
That's when you know he's really one.
I go first.
Oh, it's okay.
Nice.
Oh, no.
He said me first.
I fucking... I went me first.
It's okay, he died.
Look, it's not my fault.
Porky literally said I ult first.
And I...
And I went first.
Alright.
Okay.
I have a little bit of the heals on me.
Oh my god, I accidentally...
I accidentally hit my right click mouse.
I accidentally hit my right click for that.
Nice.
I got you!
Heal soon.
Come back.
Mag's on point.
Mag's in front.
Mag's one.
No!
I was one.
He's still one.
No support.
Can I touch?
He fucked up portal.
Why did no one shoot the mag?
What?
Oh my god.
It's really rough because it's like...
What do we do?
I think three tank bad.
Yeah, this Psylocke is very annoying.
Wise words.
So wise.
Okay.
Things will be fine.
Things will be okay.
And Nemo was open, yeah?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
No, that Psylocke is doing so much.
He's doing so much and like...
And like, it's fucking me over.
Okay, I have my armor.
Ooh.
Team up time.
We're trying trying.
Yup, I have knife.
Oh my god, he missed.
Okay, I was gonna say.
If he missed that knife, I was gonna be...
I was gonna be a little sad.
Okay.
Oh my god.
They're doing so much damage.
I'm flaming him.
Hey.
I'm clapping, I'm clapping, I'm clapping, I'm clapping.
I'm clapping, I'm clapping.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh my god.
I don't have enough!
I was so close!
I was 5%!
NOOOOOO!
Let's see who we can draw, maybe.
Drawable.
It's so drawable.
We couldn't build ult fast enough.
We couldn't get ult charge fast enough there.
It's so drawable.
You're so right, guys.
It's just pretty bad right now because we don't have another DPS player.
They do.
We have three tank players.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
He's gonna fucking kill me.
Oh my god.
I think even if we healed each other as supports, we'd still die to it.
Unless we all stacked to it.
We didn't all stack to it.
We weren't stacking together.
That's the only way to heal it.
I think I trust my supports more.
I trust my supports to all be together.
The guardians of the galaxy...
What?
Oh, oh.
Maybe TP, TP, TP.
They're gonna TP, guys.
TP, TP, TP behind, guys.
Slow, slow, slow, slow.
I'm scared.
I can't choke here.
Slow, slow, slow.
We have D.Va.
Let them push, let them push a little bit.
Rotate, rotate.
I've res, I've res, I've res.
I can't touch point, guys.
Strange low.
Strange, strange, strange, strange.
Strange on a Raccoon.
Okay, it's okay.
I'm scared.
Strange one.
I have strange on me.
Strange frozen.
Strange one.
Strange, back on me.
I have to heal.
Ouch, point.
No!
They just walked up.
That's all they do.
Oh my god.
They're just doing whatever they want.
How do you win?
That's a very good question.
They just walked up slowly to me and just started hitting me.
Like, what do I do?
What do I do?
When they just walked up to me and just bashed my head.
Like, no one to challenge them.
Yeah.
Unfortunately.
It's just very unfortunate.
Yeah, we just ended up, you know, damaged.
We literally just walked down.
I did.
I ran away and they just kept walking up to me.
I couldn't run away too far because I had to heal my tank.
But like, I was actually crazy.
I just...
There was no way to go.
There was...
Well, I can't believe Gomez is a silver one player.
Damn.
I can't believe.
I can't...
Damn, he's really fell off, guys.
MRI really fucked him up, guys.
He's an actual silver player.
Damn.
I'm sending that.
Looks legit to me.
Oh my god.
That's...
That's sad, guys.
I can't believe it.
What do you mean I blame Meat Doki?
What the fuck did I do?
I do!
I can't believe Sen...
Gomez from Sentinels is a silver one player.
Oh my god.
Guys, Identity Theft is a little funny though.
It is.
Oh my god!
You lose...
Gomez lost in silver?!
Oh my god!
Number one Furmes fan.
Okay.
Wow.
I can't believe it.
He deranked a lot.
What?
Getting third in MR...
Oh my god.
Get...
I can't believe it.
He got third in MRI and then now he deranked all the way to silver.
That's sad.
Wasn't my fault though.
I was streaming other stuff during MRI.
Can't blame me.
Alright, who are we playing against?
I think we're playing against the same people.
That Doomcube was fucking crazy.
Yeah.
How many games do you have to lose to even go from eternity to like silver?
All the mighty have fallen.
Truly a sad time.
Okay.
But we have the same Venom player, I'm pretty sure.
I'm banning Groot.
I don't want to deal with Groot.
I don't care if they don't like that.
They can... I'm on stream mode so they don't know.
Yay!
Yo, two lose.
You okay?
Yeah.
As long as you lose with...
As long as you lose with me.
What?
Okay, I'm banning.
Yeah, I'm banning anyway.
What the fuck does this mean?
What?
I can't trust him.
I...
What does that mean?
Okay.
Okay, I'm...
I don't... I'm not typing anything.
I'm not typing anything.
Guys,
I don't trust him.
Did we ban Adam?
Wait, we didn't.
What if I go Adam?
I want to go Adam.
Let's try.
Let's try this.
Okay.
Alright, let's try.
We didn't ban Adam.
So it might work.
Adam with Starlord Res is always good.
Okay.
Okay, if it doesn't work, I'll swap.
Oh, they actually...
No, they have the...
Yeah, they have the...
Oh, I did not want to use that.
That wasn't gonna...
I think I wasn't gonna get healing time.
Okay, I'm trying to be...
Whoa!
Okay.
Trying to be...
Selected with my heals right now.
What?!
Jesus Chri...
Oh my god, that's a hot guy right there.
That's a hot guy right there.
I don't have heals.
Okay.
Oh no, not halfway.
Oh no.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Nice.
I'll just stay here.
There's nothing bad's gonna...
Something bad happened to us.
Something absolutely terrible happened to us, guys.
Something...
Something bad happened to us.
Yes.
Guys.
Guys, I...
Think something bad happened to us.
Oh no, this is bad for me.
This is actually bad for me.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Well, I have rez, but...
Wait, they have one support?!
Wait a minute!
Wait a...
What the fuck?!
Okay.
Okay, I'm rezzing and then I'm fucking swapping to Luna.
One for one, okay.
We just need to kill Invis.
That's it.
Literally, that's our whole plan.
That's our entire plan.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's...
Whoa, we used a lot of ults.
Whoa.
That's a lot.
Wait, what's behind us?
Who's behind us?
There's a Psylocke behind.
Oh no, he's fucking serious.
That's when you know.
Okay, that's when you know he's serious.
Okay.
Oh, I'm a little worried about...
Okay, wait, where is he going?
Okay.
Fuck me, I guess.
I guess.
I got headshot.
I got headshot, I guess.
Literally existed in the Luna ult just to die.
I love it.
I love it when that happens.
Don't you just love it when...
Yeah, I can rez this.
Okay.
Oh, you only have Adam heals.
Adam heals.
I mean, that's just like...
I have to use soul.
They've been 4 DPS since the beginning!
Yes!
Okay.
Oh, I do not have anything for that.
Bro, okay, this Hawkeye is insane.
This Hawkeye is actually insane.
Oh my god.
This Hawkeye is insane.
I'm soul bonding.
Nice.
Jesus.
Bro.
Oh my god.
Are they still...
They're still 4 DPS.
How are they getting away with this?
Oh my...
They just kill us before we can kill them.
Bro, I'm scared.
I'm actually scared of him.
There's Pupil behind us.
Oh,
I have ult, but I'm scared.
Oh my god.
I have res.
I have to soul bond us.
Oh!
No!
Okay, their Hawkeye is actually fucking insane though.
I don't know if I should go Mantis.
Oh, fuck it.
I'll run back Luna.
Adam was not working.
We bubble Sven, okay?
Bubble Sven.
Alright.
Adam not working.
I go Luna.
How the fuck?
Jesus Christ.
They're fucking...
Their Hawkeye is actually crazy.
Goodbye.
I have a Psylocke behind me.
Oh my god.
We need help.
Backline needs help.
Help Backline or Backline cry.
Please.
Help Backline or Backline sad.
Backline cry.
I don't want to get deleted again.
Oh my god.
I'm like most afraid of...
I'm most afraid of like...
Okay, okay.
I'm in.
Oh my god.
Who the fuck is over there though?
Oh.
There's a Psylocke behind us.
Where is he?
Psylocke is still behind us.
I hear him.
Oh, he's over there.
Oh my god.
I don't...
Get him out of here.
Oh my god.
Out of...
The craziest part is that all the DPS did not swap out with DPS.
That's...
That's the craziest part.
This hot guy is scary.
I have no idea who the areas was...
Who areas...
Who this person was.
Yeah.
Honestly, we look like trash.
If only we had Choppa.
Gomez getting diff'd.
Choppa would carry.
Choppa would've carried.
You're so right.
He would've.
I wish Choppa was here, guys.
Choppa would've carried us all.
100%.
You need me.
5...
4...
3...
2...
I have 3.
Okay, okay.
I'm pushing, Kite.
Oh, you're so far.
You're so far.
Oh no.
No, it's okay.
It's okay.
Wait, they're two supports now.
Oh my god.
Why try now?
I love you too.
Oh my...
Oh my gosh.
Whoa.
What a bromance.
No homo.
Are all the homo?
Two supports.
No, don't say that.
Start believing.
Oh shit, there's a Hawkeye.
Okay.
I go here.
Yeah, I go.
Okay, guys.
I stopped...
I stopped believing because I saw the Syla.
So I got scared.
Okay, start believing, guys.
Start believing in...
Guys, start believing.
Guys, it's possible.
Just start believing.
They're actually doing worse with two supports.
They should swap back to one.
They actually...
They actually should just go back to one.
Wait, they are.
They are.
They're like, wait a minute.
We're doing worse.
They have Rocket now.
They actually win.
That's crazy.
That's actually so fucking hilarious.
Okay.
Invis, use ult first.
Oh shit, nice.
Okay.
I don't know if we needed to do it from here, but that's okay.
Oh my god.
Where are we?
We die.
Let's just...
Yeah, we just...
We just die, I guess.
Wait,
they're running triple support.
Wait, what?
What happened?
Now they don't believe in themselves anymore?
None of the DPS believe now.
What happened?
Guys, I missed the four DPS comp.
I think it would have worked.
They don't believe.
They don't fucking believe in themselves.
That's so sad.
Imagine not believing anymore.
Oh my god, no!
Nice, we have Rez.
Rez is back here.
I have a Psylocke behind.
Oh no.
We didn't see that Rez.
Wait, unless...
We still have Adam.
Yippee!
Oh, I need to skate back.
I'm skating.
I'm skating, guys.
I'm still skating.
I'm skating.
Oh my god, what's going on?
No!
He took so much damage!
That's crazy!
I got it.
Come over, come over.
I'm damage boosting.
Get strange.
Is the Psylocke to the left?
Oh, I knew it!
I knew he had ult too!
I could see it!
It was there by the way!
Okay, that's unlucky.
That's...
That's unlucky.
I missed four support...
I missed four DPS.
When can we have our four DPS back?
Four DPS was so fun, guys.
It was so fun.
Jesus...
Stop!
Actually, you're feeding.
Stop.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Wait, my mouse died!
Oh my god, no!
My mouse is dead!
Oh my god, she's through.
I actually did.
My mouse died.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm so unlucky!
My mouse is dead!
That's so unlucky!
I'll touch if you TP.
Oh my god.
I can't believe that happened.
I can't believe!
Holy shit!
I got her.
No, no, no, I got her.
Nope, I got her.
Wait, we don't have passive!
Oh!
Oh, go Misu!
Oh my...
It's okay, they don't know.
They don't know.
They don't know my mouse DC'd.
They actually don't know.
As long as they don't know...
As long as they don't know my mouse DC'd, it's fine.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
I had...
My mouse was not charged.
I didn't realize I was playing on my...
Nobody's...
I didn't realize I was playing with like...
10% mouse battery when I started the stream.
I...
Guys, I was winning in solo queue.
That's all I'll say.
Guys...
I was winning in solo queue.
True.
One game is still one win.
It's still a win.
It's okay, I'm having a fun time though.
I'm having a fun time with Chopper.
And Chopper.
With just Chopper.
LOL
That's pretty good.
We have the same random player.
Is this...
The same guy?
Is this Stab?
Did we just ban Psylocke?
Okay.
What did I say?
It's okay.
Games will get better, right?
Guys...
Guys, games are getting better right now.
This will be it.
This will be the moment where games get a little better.
Alright, who's gonna win that 50-50?
Oh, nice.
Can't get worse.
You're right.
Review, thank you for the tier 1 sub.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
How could it get worse?
It's okay.
We all know...
Who's the...
Who's the lowest ranked player here.
It is Gomez.
MRI...
Sentinels did not treat them...
Well, not Sentinels.
But MRI did not treat Sentinels well.
In Fight Night.
Music makes people happy.
Nobody 6 sacks in high elo.
They have to wait like 6 hours to get a game.
You're right.
Wait, Raccoon.
Or maybe it's just for the heals.
I need to put it on Groot.
I'm Groot.
I am Groot.
Can't wait to get Groot dipped.
Woah!
They queue their matches before bed so it's ready when they wake up.
That's actually smart.
Their alarm is when the game queues up.
Gets in.
I actually wanna see like people 6 sacking and just see how long the queue is.
They just like leave their PC on and just see how long it'll take.
Oh my god, it's so hard playing with a wired mouse.
I do not like...
Oh my god.
I hate...
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
Oh my god.
It is not fun.
Oh my god, my aim.
My aim.
You see that?
I didn't even know I was aiming at anybody.
He went to Human Torch?
Wait, does he just throw?
Does he just throw?
Don't jinx us.
Oh my god.
He died because you said that.
We actually...
We actually lost fucking to the Human Torch.
That's crazy.
That's actually so funny.
We fucking...
I'm ulting in.
Oh god.
Okay.
I like...
I like he's like...
Oh, so he's throwing.
And he's throwing because we banned Psylocke.
And then literally our Bucky dies.
By the Human Torch.
That's actually crazy.
Tronny heard you talking shit.
That was scary.
I just got hit by like a giant ball of fire.
Like I didn't know how to fucking...
How to fucking react to that.
Oh.
Please.
Am I okay?
No!
I'm not okay.
Was not okay.
What did he say?
Can't tell.
They used everything though.
They still have...
I couldn't tell.
He was like mumbling so much.
Oh my god, Tree.
Don't die, Tree.
Don't die.
Oh god.
Don't die, Tree.
Oh!
Tree.
I might be dead.
Nice.
Nice, we're okay.
Yeah?
What did he say?
What is...
Yo, no die.
I whip you.
I extra die.
You're right.
How could I give up when I have number one mercy player.
Thank god.
I can't.
Oh my god.
Wait, that was just an AK-47.
Where the fuck did that...
Never give up like John Cena.
Wait.
Jesus.
Never give up, guys.
Remember what...
Now John Cena didn't even say that.
I didn't even let John Cena think.
Oh my god.
Nice.
I'm not gonna say more on what he just said.
I'll just say, how do you say invisible woman in Japanese?
But then I got scared.
I don't know what he'll say.
Wait, you die.
You can die, you can die, you can die.
I will, I will.
Oh my god.
Okay, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
I die.
Wait, he lied.
Chopper lied.
He said I would never die.
I believe it.
He lied to me.
He told me it would never happen.
He said it would never happen.
How did it happen?
I got him, I got him.
He's fine.
Wait,
Torch, Torch, Torch.
First one.
What?
The fuck was that?
He lied twice.
He did.
I can't believe it.
Never believe when they say, don't worry, you don't die.
Don't believe.
It's a lie.
What the fuck?
That's actually bullshit.
I should not have died like that.
I have no idea who the fuck I froze there.
You first, you first, Torch.
Okay.
Alright.
Wait, shield.
Okay.
Two.
One.
Mag on point.
Oh my god, I can aim.
Oh my god.
We did it.
Chop, potty, better support than tank.
True.
Oh my god, we did it.
We broke the cycle.
We broke the curse.
Damn, dude.
That's not true.
That is, in what fucking world am I a better DPS than support?
And why are you cooking my dude?
He consented!
Look, look, look.
Right here.
I'm going to retire from tank.
I go support win.
Go tank lose.
And I'll eat better.
He literally consented.
It's not my fault.
Oh my god, you're right.
It's because I pulled.
You're right.
Oh my god, I forgot my incredible Starlord game right there.
You're so right, guys.
You're so right, chat.
I almost forgot about that incredible Starlord game that I played on my other monitor.
Oh my gosh.
How could I forget, chat?
I can't believe I would forget such a monumentous play that I just did there on my other PC.
Honestly, yeah.
That's why I could've...
Honestly, I could be like...
I could be like top 10 right now if I wasn't, you know, if I was actually playing on one account.
But I just have to nerf myself in some way, you know, chat?
Yeah, it just wouldn't be fair.
It literally just wouldn't be fair to everybody around me.
Right.
Yeah, exactly.
Thank god I'm private profile.
So other players can't judge me.
Alright, we'll do...
Okay, livestream three hours.
Okay, we'll do...
We'll do one more.
One LG.
This is LG.
And we'll lose, but like, this is LG.
We won't lose!
Never give up, like what Choppa said.
Never give up like John Cena.
Guys, I hope I don't get cancelled when I wake up.
It's like...
Guys...
Choppa views do not represent me.
His views do not represent me, guys.
Ranking Twitlonger right now.
It's okay.
I...
I don't know if it's okay, but like, it's okay.
It's okay.
Oh shit, Nekros is playing.
Okay, he's in practice range.
I don't have to worry about that.
Wait, did Pearl...
Is Pearl's rank right now?
Oh my god!
He climbed to five...
Oh.
Whoa.
I know he always duos with...
No, he didn't.
Usually he always plays with a Mantis player.
Pearl is like...
I know two Widow players that are really scary.
And it's Pearl and i8.
I do not...
Like, I am very scared of Pearl and i8's Widow.
Not sure for it.
Not as...
He doesn't one trick Widow.
That's the thing.
But Pearl...
Pearl and...
Pearl and i8 one trick Widow.
Pearl has been hackusated so many times.
Number one player of the year.
Be my mercy damage boost.
Mercy pocket.
Number one mercy player.
Player of the year.
What's PO?
What?
Player...
Of the year.
What the fuck is he talking about?
It's alright.
I've already been in a Necros.
I've already been in a Necros clip but...
I can be in another one.
Oh, Potty!
For some reason I thought he said player of the year.
He was trying to say Potty.
It's like...
I thought he was trying to say...
I'm so confused.
I like one trick.
I like one trick again.
I thought he said player of the year.
I don't know why.
I thought he said Potty.
Fuck that guy.
I don't know why.
I forgot his name.
I forgot his name is Potty.
No, I'm not okay.
I'm not okay.
This is LG for me.
Nemo and then Groot.
We ban Groot.
We ban Groot?
Can we do it?
Why does he want to play Groot?
Hello?
This is his fault.
Wait, this is my fault because he's me.
I'm him.
Who's Ubi?
I have no idea who Ubi is.
How much battery I have?
Okay, 28.
Guys, LG, 28%.
I can do it.
28% on my mouse.
It's doable.
It's so doable.
My time is now like John Cena.
Okay.
This is fine.
This works.
You're watching me.
We're watching DokiBird on two different accounts.
That's who you're watching.
I'm me.
I'm her.
I'm Doki.
Potty might as well be my- Wait, no, he's not.
He has some fucked up shit.
I do not want to be associated with Potty.
I'm all of them except for Potty.
I gotta make sure.
I don't want to be canceled.
Oh, I need to reload.
Oh, wow.
Three top again.
Oh, two top.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ, so much damage.
There's so much damage.
Dammit.
All I'm doing is healing.
This is all I'm doing.
Oh my god.
Doing that thing.
You all first.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
Are they gonna triple support?
They are.
Maybe I just freeze them.
Oh my god, I don't know who it is!
Get frozen!
I love it when they all stand in one line for me.
It's really helpful.
Um, okay.
Okay, it's fine.
I don't feel fine.
Oh.
Okay.
It's okay.
It's not okay, but it's okay.
I believe...
They have...
They still have human torch ult.
That's why I didn't...
I didn't ult because they still have human torch ult, so there was no point.
We were already down one.
See, look at that.
Analysis.
That's how you use your brain!
Oh my god, I'm in a square.
There we go!
Damn it.
I did it, I did it, I did it.
Oh.
That's unfortunate.
That's very unfortunate for me.
JK, I'm alive.
Oh my god, three low.
Please.
Oh my god, I'm okay.
I'm so...
I'm not, but like, I'm okay.
Oh my god, he's doing that thing.
And he's dead.
Okay, nice.
Double kill.
Please tell me.
Please.
Big one.
Poopy.
Ban him in your chat.
I will.
I believed in the power of stole bond.
Ban him.
That's what we did.
Oh my god, we lost because of it!
Oh my god.
Why?
Why we have three supports?
We have three supports, why are you scared?
How could you be scared?
There's three of us.
Oh my god.
Where's my...
Where are they?
I...
Oh, damage.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Unless...
No goodbye.
Goodbye.
I think this is...
This is goodbye.
Right there.
No, that's definitely goodbye.
No, that's...
Oh my god.
Okay, not LG, I'm avoiding Ube.
I will not have anybody throwing my game for stream snipe content.
I refuse.
Alright.
Oh my god, goodbye.
Oh no.
I'm trying my best to keep you alive, but it's very difficult.
It's very difficult.
I'm trying so hard to keep you alive.
Oh my god, there was no way.
There was no way.
We were just dead dead.
We were actually just dead dead.
Yeah, oh.
Oh.
You all first.
Okay.
This is good.
He used...
Oh my god.
We didn't kill anybody, but that's okay.
Because we have this.
Okay, okay.
2, 1, damage, damage, damage.
I damaged.
I did my job.
Okay, I didn't die to...
I didn't...
Did not die to Maggle.
I didn't die to Maggle.
That was rough.
I think we could have actually got that push there.
If we did the invis ult right there.
That's too much overconfidence.
You should never be overconfident in rank.
Because you don't trust...
You can't trust anybody.
You can't...
Not even...
Not even my own teammates.
My damage boost didn't work against the Pati out there.
Or Choppa.
No, especially not me.
Especially not me.
Trust no one.
Even your own group.
You trust nobody.
Oh shit, no more Venom.
No more Venom.
What the fuck?
Why Link?
The cooldown is so long.
Oh no.
It's one of the longest Adam cooldowns out there.
I'm scared.
Spin you, spin, spin, spin, spin.
No Link.
I don't know who the fuck I did it to.
But...
I did it.
Okay.
He's spinning, he's spinning, he's spinning, he's spinning, he's spinning, he's spinning.
Oh my god.
I'm healing.
Oh no!
I'll ult first, I'll ult first.
Oh my god.
I'm...
I'm damage boosting.
No!
Oh shit.
Woah!
Huge TP.
Why?
Choppa, why?
Choppa!
Huge TP.
They have Starlord ult.
It's okay.
As long as we're not on it, it should be fine, right?
My fault.
No, no.
I get the strength, I get the strength.
Oh, I can't see you Choppa.
We got Starlord left.
Hold after this.
He's pushing.
There's a mag by himself.
Sustain, sustain.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
They're gonna slam it.
Medivh's on.
Okay.
Okay, we can walk now.
Come on, NB.
I spin, I spin.
NB, I'm on him.
Alright, alright.
I'm on NB.
Oh, no.
No, I just need...
Oh, I was 3%.
Oh, 3%.
No.
Okay.
It's fine.
It's okay.
I froze.
I did my job.
I'll up first.
Alright.
You doing it?
Here we go.
3, 2, 1.
NB!
Now we walk, walk, walk.
NB, we're alive!
I don't want to jinx it.
We're almost...
We were alive.
Now, now we're just trying to live.
Now we're just...
Whoa!
I walked with you.
Oh!
Oh, nice.
This is so bad.
I'm not scared.
I am scared.
I...
I'm still scared.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm still scared.
Oh, there they are.
Goodbye.
It's okay, we got the choppa TP!
The choppa TP!
Where am I?
I just dropped straight down.
I miss choppa support.
I miss when he was on support, guys.
Okay, I'll do one more.
I'll do one more there.
I'll do one more.
Okay, I will...
I'll let...
I'll let go.
Do I avoid Ubi for his crime?
Yes!
He has spoken.
Alright.
Alright, this is last game for real.
He has committed crime.
We can't...
You're right, we can't leave on a loss, guys.
True.
What are we banning?
I'm banning Groot.
I'm gonna ban Groot.
Okay, we ban Groot and then Psylocke.
I'd rather deal with the Human Torch than Psylocke.
We ban Human Torch.
Yeah, he plays Human Torch.
Ubi, it's not the one thing...
It's not just the one thing wrong.
It's when you said to our faces that...
That we will be okay.
And that was the crime.
You lied!
That was the crime.
Look, Choppa can get away with it.
Because English is not his first language.
So it was a miscommunication.
He has the pass.
He's still learning.
The ice effects look great on stage.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready!
Also,
I won when Choppa lied.
I didn't win when Ubi lied.
Him lying actually is beneficial to the team.
Bottom, they give a tier 1 sub gift to Phantom.
Real.
Exactly.
Where's the rest of my team?
Oh, there they are.
Did the Human Torch again?
Oh my god, it is.
What kind of hero pool do you have?
That's literally...
Um...
That's literally like, uh...
Human Torch Psylocke.
Like, that is a fucking weird ass hero pool.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm coming over.
Oh my gosh, I guess I'm not coming over.
Oh, goodbye.
I didn't realize the Loki ran off.
I was confused.
I was like, where did my Loki go?
I was so...
I was so confused.
I was like, wait, my Loki's gone.
I got...
I was so confused.
Like, how did he disappear?
He was right next to me when we were...
When we were fucking...
Dealing with that Venom and then he left me?
That should've been a hit.
That absolutely should've been a kill.
That should've been a hit on the freeze.
I don't know how that didn't hit.
I'm getting shot from the back.
There is a Human Torch behind us for sure.
Yeah, there he is.
Oh, Mag is ulted.
Then hello.
And Mag no ult.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
We should be okay.
For now.
I shouldn't jinx this.
But like...
At this moment of time, I am okay.
That's how I'm gonna say it.
At this moment of time.
Jesus Christ.
Jesus.
Yeah, fuck that one guy.
Oh my god.
Fuck me, I guess too.
Wow.
Let's run through this fight.
Okay, nice.
Jesus Christ, Chopper.
Oh my god.
Where's Mag?
Oh, wait!
Wait.
Guru's on our team.
Which one is Gale?
Frozen Venom?
Nice.
I just noticed.
Oh!
No!
I'm alive.
Oh.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry!
I was not fine.
Wait, I am fine.
I got three.
I got three of them.
No supports.
I'm coming back.
Oh!
Supports are here now.
He didn't look at me?
Or copy?
Oh my god.
Are you okay?
Nice.
Wait, Loki low!
We did it.
Oh, so Guru's just...
Guru's solo queue right now.
Nice.
Yay!
Oh my god!
Okay.
That would've been so cool if I hit that.
Guys, I wish I...
I think if I didn't get Ricocheted, I would've hit it.
I think I would've...
I think if I didn't bounce up, I could've hit it.
Doki Bird.
Yes, I'm Doki Bird.
What is Doki Bird?
Do you know Doki Bird fans 69?
That's Hulus.
I don't know who Doki Bird fans 69 is.
Google it.
I should be...
I am...
I'm not Doki Bird.
I am Donkey Kong.
You guys should Google.
Yeah, he's the number one rapper in Japan.
Yes, 100.
The potty monkey?
Oh my god.
What?
You're crazy.
That wolf's looking for an ult.
The wolf has no passive.
1, 2, 3.
Go, go, go.
I'm already dead.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I lost track of where he was.
Don't tell him I did not do it.
Don't tell him I missed.
He doesn't know.
That wolf ult here.
What?
More,
go, go.
Go to your spawn.
Wait.
Back out, T9.
What the...
He's gone.
Are you guys okay?
Oh yeah.
What?
He did not want that back pass.
He did not want it.
Understandable.
Okay.
Okay, let's let the Navel Guru, let's let him go.
Are you okay?
Kappa?
He's not okay.
Oh my god, he lived.
I froze Venom.
Hello to the right.
Oh, I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming.
Damage boosting, damage boosting.
Go.
Yo, you, oh my god, oh my god.
Who is on the thing right now?
Go, go, go.
Invis is coming over.
One more.
Who's on the thing right now?
I spawn capped, I spawn capped, I spawn capped.
Go!
Go, go, go, go.
Maglo, Maglo too.
Oh my god, they're all low.
I can't see you, oh.
Okay.
Guys,
I don't have ult here.
Choco, why can't you do that?
Can win.
Can win, can win, can win.
Can win, can win.
Guys.
Bro, I literally damage boost Trump every time.
Guys,
I don't think the thing was it.
I don't know.
I think we definitely did better when we're not on the thing.
I think, I think, I think we actually were doing better without being on the thing.
Why are you touching me?
What?
He wants to throw me and you're not touching me.
Everything changed when he swapped to the thing.
I think he was definitely a better, he was what?
He was a better mag player.
Was he a mag, right?
Nice.
Hello, hello.
Oh my god, he couldn't Q.
I did, I pressed ult, but it didn't go off.
I went, I pressed Q, it didn't go off.
I didn't actually got pinged there.
That actually went off on my, I pressed Q.
Yeah, I don't know why it didn't go off.
I pressed Q for it too, I spammed it.
Oh no.
I tried my best.
Oh my god.
I spammed Q.
Okay.
Oh my god.
No, I got combo'd.
Come on, we died, we lost a good time.
I got combo'd, what do you want from me?
We, I am not the problem here.
When we went mag, we were doing really well.
The thing, our thing is not like the best player.
He should be playing...
Oh boy, oh boy, oh boy.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh!
Oh my god.
I literally...
I freeze him every time.
I've always frozen him.
Oh no!
That's fucked.
I don't know why we went the thing.
I don't know why.
I feel like we should've swapped.
We should've swapped the thing to... we should've stayed...
Mag.
He was doing so well on mag.
Literally, we couldn't do anything with it.
Oh!
And then I got blamed.
I was like, I pressed Q.
Oh, it doesn't crash.
Oh!
They fixed it.
I don't know why he stayed on the thing.
He was literally doing so much on mag.
He was not getting, he was not getting picked up.
If he... okay, why the fuck is he playing on NA if he hates NA players?
Yeah, but he wasn't getting killed as mag when they were Wolverine.
And then I got blamed when they comboed me.
I was like, what do... I can't live when they venom Luna.
They're like, Luna, why you die?
I was like, I don't know, they venom Luna damage boosted me.
Like, what do I do?
We couldn't venom, we didn't venom Luna damage, but they did.
Yeah, why would you, if you hate NA so much, don't Q in our region.
Don't, stop playing EU.
Can you ult for the overseer to survive that?
I don't, I could've, yeah, I could've ulted it, but like, I didn't, I couldn't, the thing is with two Luna ults, I didn't realize they, we did, they were doing the venom.
They were, I didn't realize they were doing the venom damage boost as well.
But like, there was no reason for me to use it.
At that time, I didn't think I had to use it because I wanted to save my Luna ult.
I wanted to save it until like, it was like, emergency type deal.
I definitely got pinged hard though.
I should not have, uh, that time when I tried to ult, that first, the third point, we trolled, second point we fucking trolled so much.
I don't know why we were trolling second point.
I don't wanna lose, I don't wanna end on a loss.
Uh, I'm banning Groot.
I don't wanna end on a loss, guys.
I've only been streaming for four hours.
Not, technically not that long.
They have the Psylocke one trick again.
Is it always him?
Wait, how do you recognize me?
Oh my god.
I don't know my voice, nevermind.
I fucking talked.
Wiggsie, I'm Wiggsie.
Oh, is that Wiggsie?
Oh.
Um, it's total hours.
I have a set amount of hours.
I need a, I need a stream per month.
And I have, I, there's, I need a, there's a lot.
Cause I did not stream enough of it.
I got the partnership late compared to everybody.
Let's see, ooh.
Why is there so many Venom players on at this time?
Why?
Got my, got my thumbnails for the day.
This week, yay.
What's wrong with Venom, man?
So boring.
But I like playing Venom, don't you think?
I'm still upset that my Q didn't go off.
Did the animation go off on my screen?
I knew I was spamming it.
I was spamming the Q button.
But it didn't go off for some reason.
Oh man.
I was too, like, bothered by the fact that I, my thing didn't go.
Oh, put it on moving.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Okay, maybe he's a better thing player.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Sorry, Venom, very sad.
Can't move.
Okay.
Oh my god, there were so many clones, I missed it!
There were so many clones.
I couldn't see where the Venom went.
I actually, I lost, I lost track.
So many damage!
Jesus Christ.
Alright, I'm on, I'm stalling for, I'm stalling for.
Okay.
3, 2, 1.
Oh, they double ulted.
Jesus Christ, what's going on?
What's going on?
I froze him.
Wait, I'm here, I'm here, I'm in front of you.
Okay, nice.
Okay, not nice, not nice.
I was like, nevermind!
That was not, did not feel good.
Alright.
I'm already halfway to my, woah, I'm already halfway to another, that's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
Oh, I thought he was going to go right side.
That's what I hate about trying to freeze Venom players sometimes, because it's like 20% is trying to predict where he's going to go, and sometimes I don't know where he's going to go.
Is that huge?
He was!
Yeah, I saw like nothing there.
I didn't see anything.
No, no, no, I meant their, woah.
No, no, no.
That was, yeah, I don't know what you guys are talking about, you did nothing unstrange.
I don't know what you guys are talking about.
I think I'm just, if I win this, I think I'm down.
Choppa, we only win when you're on support, Choppa.
I think Choppa.
Choppa should be my Mercy, my Mercy pocket.
He's number one Mercy player.
GP, man, no play except play.
Choppa, you don't want to be my Mercy main?
Man.
Hop on, hop on, hop on.
Oh yeah, here we go, here we go, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Woah!
Choppa, Choppa, heal.
What is this?
I like stood still.
Oh,
man.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh.
He did the damage boost.
Why can't Choppa do that?
Why can't Choppa do that when he's on Venom, guys?
Oh, shit!
Sorry, I was looking at chat.
My bad.
I should stop looking at chat.
JK, I would never stop.
Oh!
Oh.
Okay.
I'm just going to move back.
Three, two, one.
Oh, no.
Nice.
Move, move, go back.
Come on, hold on, hold on.
I have an idea.
Are they worried here now?
What's your idea?
Come back.
Go back, Choppa.
They don't have a world coming?
Oh, yeah.
A whole world.
Thanks.
Sorry.
You're too far.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I like the cold.
Wait, where...
Where is this portal?
It's on the high ground.
What, you don't see it?
No, I didn't!
It worked, though.
Okay.
Okay, it worked.
Yeah, see?
It worked, though.
What?
High ground?
I looked down.
I was like, where am I?
I can't believe you crashed into my TP.
Bro, that...
That was a pretty bad TP.
I don't even know how we won that fight.
Come here, come here, come here.
I press ult, I press ult.
I'm with you, I'll cover mine.
They're on left side.
Left side, hello, hello, left side.
Chase, help me point, help me point.
I'm trying, I'm reloading.
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
That guy...
I'm chasing him.
You got this, I believe in you.
Shut him off.
Wait, we're stalling him, right?
Go, go, go!
Drop it!
Oh, man.
Yeah, we're staggering him.
You go first, you go first.
Yeah, I'll go first.
Luna first, Luna.
We're gonna try to do the combo again.
I'm using
it.
Where are you, Venom?
Oh, you went all the way there?
What the heck?
Oh, my God, where's my Luna?
I'm
like...
Oh, my God!
Okay, we might need a TP.
Also, I got a kill.
I can touch, maybe.
Wait, I can TP, what am I talking about?
Oh!
Wait,
where are we?
Oh, my God.
I can't see anything!
Okay.
I think Gomez is gonna get off of TP duty.
I need to TP!
I can't!
Could I go back to...
Could I go back to DPS?
It could be kind of fun.
A little bit of fun.
He's not thinking with portals right now.
He's not.
You wanna have me on tank?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that sounds okay.
Let's do that fuck.
Thank God.
After that last TP, I don't...
I don't trust their strange anymore.
Why would he be?
The last two.
The last two, true.
The last two were pretty...
pretty weird.
There's no way.
There's no way you guys think it was my fault.
I mean...
It's not your fault.
You might not be a strange player.
You might not be a strange player, that's for sure.
But maybe not Dr. Strange.
Yeah, he definitely did not get his doctorate.
He called me a strange player.
I was an intern.
Goddamnit.
Free point.
I don't think it's free anymore.
Oh, no.
I wish my Bucky did that.
I don't have a Bucky.
Oh, if I bully you, it makes me look less bad.
Oh, I just held tab.
I see why.
Sorry about that.
I'll go first.
I'm the ulti.
Oh, I might be dead to this.
Oh, nevermind.
I'm alive!
Okay.
Oh, this is so boring.
This is Venom.
This is Venom, man.
What a boring character.
God.
Guys...
Guys, I don't...
Guys, I don't know if I can win anymore.
Guys, I'm losing more and more hope.
I'm...
I'm losing...
more and more hope right now.
I don't want.
I'm losing
more and more hope, guys.
I'm losing...
Guys...
I'm a little scared now.
Yeah, I'm not standing here anymore.
I'm a little scared standing up here, but okay.
I go first.
Can I help?
I don't know what you were saying.
I'm ulting.
Oh...
3, 2, 1...
No!
Wait, we have portal, right?
Or no?
No.
Okay.
I believe.
No!
Alright, we're banning Venom.
No more of this Venom bullshit.
That character is so...
God.
Why can't Gomez do that?
I know, right?
Guys, we're getting on a loss, guys.
We're getting on a loss.
Getting on a loss is... Guys, that's not us, guys.
I can get it all back.
It's fine.
We still have a streak, yeah?
We don't talk about it.
We don't... Technically, we don't talk about it, guys.
We don't talk about the loss streak.
It's okay.
Things are gonna...
Things will be... Now that we banned Venom, things will be better now, guys.
Now that we know what to ban, we will be fine.
We will be fine.
Fine, you're right.
I need my... What's this?
Saratoga water?
To refresh myself.
We don't talk about it.
It gets better, guys.
It always gets better.
It's okay.
We're learning.
Oh?
Oh, I thought they changed something.
Guys, it's okay.
I can always get... I can always climb back.
I can always climb back.
I have 16 days.
It's okay.
I have 16 days to always come back up.
It's fine.
Things will be okay.
You're right.
You're right, guys.
It's not Chapa's fault.
It's okay.
The longer I stream...
The longer I stream, the more I'm fitting the quota of my hours.
That's all that matters.
The longer I stream, the more hours I get.
And that's what we're here for.
We're just here for the hours.
You're right, though.
Why couldn't my Bucky do what their Bucky did?
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's just...
If we win one more game, we're only down two games, guys.
We just need to win one more game, and we're just down two games.
Also, like...
Those pointers were pretty...
Okay, the high ground portal...
The high ground portal was very...
Was definitely interesting.
Oh, you're right.
If we win four games, we're up.
You're so right.
We're up a game if we win four games.
You're so right, guys.
You're so right.
No, maybe three games.
Maybe...
I think we can win three games, guys.
I think that's possible.
And if we win five, we'll be up two games.
You're so right, guys.
Thank God I don't have a stream tomorrow.
My doctor was like, you gotta rest your throat.
Wait.
You wanna get better?
Oh, shit.
It's 4-0-2.
Okay, if we win this, I'm calling it.
If we win the next game, I'm actually calling it.
Jokey, I need to sleep?
If I don't need to sleep, you'll be fine.
Okay, actually, if you guys need to sleep, go sleep.
If you guys need to sleep, go sleep, guys.
Neko, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Warrior, thank you for the 20 bits.
Phantom, thank you for gifting a Tier 1 sub to Gomez and Ube.
Wait, Gomez was never... Oh my God, fake fan.
Delta, thank you for gifting a Tier 1 sub.
And Phantom, thank you for gifting five Tier 1 subs.
Thank you, thank you.
This is why Choppa's my favorite.
I don't even think he streams.
But he doesn't pretend to be a...
He doesn't pretend to be a dragon, at least.
That's fucking right.
I said it.
Yeah, I said it.
I'm gonna do a match to pass the time.
Oh, Choppa's... Oh, I should not.
Nevermind, I just remembered.
Nevermind, I did not mean that.
I just remembered all...
I just remembered the stuff he said.
Guys, I don't mean that.
Wait, I can't go up here?
What's the point of a staircase?
Wait, what?
Are they not here to fight?
What's the point of doing matches?
What?
Are we just chilling?
Oh, shit.
I didn't know this was a chill circle!
Oh my god.
I didn't know we were supposed to be chilling.
This is a chill circle?
Look, I was... I misunderstood.
I misunderstood.
This sucks.
This is a chill Doom Patrol.
This is a...
It's not?
Oh my god.
What the fuck happened to me?
Hello.
Wait, are we all fighting now?
What's going on?
Are we not chill?
We ain't chill like that.
Is this what Doom is like?
Doom Q like?
There's no one... No one wants to fight?
Is that what it's like in these queues?
Okay, but what if like... Okay.
What if I just start a war?
Oh, nice.
Reminded me to start a war.
The Loki started a war.
What have I just caused?
Oh my god.
We're in the trenches.
Celestia!
We're actually in the trenches now.
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
What's up?
We're down here.
I'm gonna play... What's his name?
Wocket.
I'm gonna play Wocket.
What?!
I'm gonna play Punisher for me.
Okay.
I'm banning Venom.
Fuck this shit.
I'm fucking...
Spider-Man?!
Bro, just ban Venom.
Yeah.
Okay.
Did he just say Wocket?
Who are the... Who are the Celestia players?
Who are the Celestia players in this lobby?
I need a note.
No, they banned.
I'm too... I'm too... Oh, dude.
I need a note.
What the fuck?
I think the Rocket is one of them.
Don't worry.
You don't need to hear me speak.
I'm just gonna hear what you're gonna give me.
I don't know what I'm saying.
These are the types of freaks you encounter in Celestia.
My Evo.
I thought he was like Wocket.
What?
I hear...
He broke my... He's inside.
He broke my thing.
Is he like Ubu topping in my lobby?
There's Namor behind us.
Namor.
Namor behind.
There's a lot of people behind us, unfortunately.
You guys heal each other.
I'll heal the other...
What the fuck?
I can't... I can't think.
I'm dead.
Yeah, you're redlining.
Watch out.
Oh my god.
We did not ban Venom.
I wish... Yeah, we did not ban... I mean, we could...
Oh my god, please.
I'm cringing a... No, I am too, guys.
You're so crazy, I guess.
I am cringing a little too.
This is so fucked.
I don't think you should play Punisher.
Yeah, I was just thinking that.
Yeah, I'm on my Bucky.
Bucky is good, still.
Come on, it's just...
Bro, he's doing ult attacks!
This is too early for ult.
This is too late at night for ult, doc.
This is way too late.
I guess I have to push a little.
We should...
I don't think he's doing a bit.
There's no way.
Do people... Wait.
Isn't, like, a lifestyle?
Do people talk like that as a lifestyle?
Like, I don't know.
How about the girls?
When the guy goes on you girls, heal each other and I'll heal both of y'all, okay?
Then miss you all first.
See it?
Yo, yo, yo, infinite assassin.
Nice.
He's like...
I'm just curious!
Is it a lifestyle?
Or, like, what?
I don't know!
That was so delightful.
How many Magnetos are alive after not getting healed for, like, 5 minutes?
Might be?
I'm so confused.
I thought he was doing that, like, out of cringe.
He's off the shark.
He's not doing that anymore.
Watch out.
Whoa.
Unfortunate.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
I'm just gonna fight on point.
Push up.
3, 2, 1.
Need more on high ground.
Yeah, I know.
Where's our GPS?
Oh, there he is.
Oh.
Oh, he fucked up.
There's a fucking guy behind us.
That'll be 5.
Oh.
Bucky behind.
Bucky's behind.
It's not Bucky that's behind.
It's fucking Irelia.
Oh my god.
Bucky was behind.
What do you mean?
He was considered behind our Magneto.
You're not the only person playing.
Stop it.
What the fuck?
He just broke my beacon instantly.
That would kill me.
This fucking Irapace is killing me.
Does anybody play Game Boy?
Oh my god.
What am I?
Oh my god, I got pushed.
Where's the ult?
Oh no.
Oh, that's where the ult was.
Fuck guys, I think I'm gonna go Namor.
Does he even play Namor?
Does he?
I could do a serviceable job probably.
I mean, shit.
Does that voice deprave people?
But like, I didn't realize some people actually talk like that.
I thought it was just done ironically.
Where is he?
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, nice.
Oh, not nice!
Nice.
Give me some healing, okay?
Thank you.
Alright.
Okay, we're fine.
We're okay.
Okay.
The- Oh my gosh, because we banned Venom, we let Namor through.
Which is also pretty fucking not great.
It's pretty...
Can you damage boost?
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god, we did it.
That- What a fucking hero pull.
Okay, that's a little bit too much ult.
Oh my god, what a fucking weird ass hero pull though.
Rocket Namor.
I- I've never seen a Rocket Namor hero pull before.
That's why I was like, damn.
You got him.
I got you, I got you.
Just one.
Alright.
Namor- Yeah, Namor is like one of the easiest DPS out there.
That's meta.
I should be specific.
Oh my god, I'm missing all my freezers on him.
Did not see it.
Oh no.
Oh, he has strange ult.
Oh my- What?!
What the fuck?
What was the de- Oh, it's E.
He timed- Oh my god.
He timed it with the E.
He did it with the E.
He slammed and stranged you at the same time.
Yeah.
If you do it with ult and E, it's like, really strong.
That's crazy.
That's a- That's a- I don't even know if that was intentional.
That's a thing.
I can't tell if that was intentional or not.
Or like, it was an accident.
Oh nice, he got hooked.
Good guy.
Oh, I don't have ult.
Just have it.
Nice!
Again!
Yippee!
We did it!
This is what 4am queues are like.
I've hit- I've hit that time.
I've hit the- I've hit the time.
I've finally bumped into people that speak UwU talk, but like, seriously.
Not ironically.
Oh!
What?
What is- What the fuck?
What is going on?
I don't even know what- It's right on my keyboard.
Look, look.
Choppa, Choppa.
Venom.
Oh!
Oh my god.
My keyboard.
My keyboard wasn't working.
I was so scared.
I was trying to get out of the keyboard.
Oh my- everything.
Oh my god.
Anymore behind?
I'll cart push.
I am cart bitch.
Oh!
What's going on with my keyboard?
Guys, there's nothing to worry about when I say that.
TP, TP.
I need heals.
Nice.
Got one.
Where are people at?
I can't tell.
Strange, strange, strange one.
Strange one.
Strange dead.
Dead, dead, dead, dead.
Nice.
You're ready to damage boost.
Oh!
Okay.
Make sure they're fucking my Nidalee.
There's a Neymar up here.
That's hella up there now.
What do you mean?!
I know my bare feet!
Guys, I know that sounded wrong the moment I said that out loud.
I know what it sounds like.
You ult first, Siv.
I'll ult first, I'll ult first.
Got him.
That's literally his sound!
That's how it sounds like when he walks!
It's the bare feet sound!
Okay, nope, nevermind, shit.
Okay, since our Neymar's dead, you can ult now, Siv.
Whatever.
Awkward.
Awkward!
Are you serious?!
Oh, where are people at?
Okay.
Awkward.
I'm scared of this champ.
He's up there.
Oh my god, please.
Okay, we got one person.
We got our only tank.
We got our only tank!
That's fine.
We have no tank.
I like the cold.
There's someone up top.
Triforce behind us, Triforce behind us.
I froze him, I froze him!
Oh, I'm dead.
I got him.
Wow, fucking hell, nice.
I'm just switching to this, this is not gonna, I wouldn't switch.
I have to get this.
He has no Flicker, man.
Oh my god.
Okay, well at least that got, he got that out of the way.
Okay.
That's awkward.
I froze him.
Oh no!
That's fine.
I couldn't, I would heal out of it.
I thought I could outheal it.
Bye, gold moon.
I don't know what to do.
Whatever, let me try something new.
Let me double tank something.
Let me try something new.
Just one.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, that would have been a good freeze.
Wait, Maglo, Maglo!
He's dead, he's dead.
Let's go, let's go.
Captain Miracle-O, Captain Miracle-O.
I got, I'm on both healers, guys.
You ready to push?
Let's go.
I got Luna, I got Luna.
There is a Jeff above us.
Can we kill him?
I'm on my healer, I'm on my healer.
I have a captain.
Oh, I don't have...
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Do we ban?
We need a strange portal.
Oh, we don't have strange.
I can't go strange too.
I can't go strange.
I have to...
I have Jeff on me.
Oh, please.
Okay, guys.
I'm gonna do something incredibly...
Oh, I can't.
Yeah.
Three, two, one.
I got, I got one.
I got one.
Oh my god.
No, we're never gonna win.
We're going forever.
We're gonna be stuck in purgatory forever.
Yeah.
Guys, we can't end on a loss.
Guys.
This can't happen.
Never ending stream.
It's obviously need one more.
Alright.
I can't believe...
Okay, I'm gonna bleed.
I do not wanna deal...
I knew it.
I knew they were the Celestial player.
I fucking knew it.
I fucking, I could tell.
I was like, there's no way.
This feels like freaky Celestial town.
Like, I...
Oh my god.
I fucking...
I was like, there's no way.
This feels like...
Oh my god.
My elo.
My fucking elo.
It's okay.
I'll get it back.
I always get it back, guys.
I can't swap accounts because I'm playing with people.
If I wasn't playing with people, I'd swap to my ult.
Oh my...
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I haven't peed at all.
I'll be right back.
Okay, guys.
It's okay.
We need to play anyway because...
We need to play anyway because we need...
We need...
The quota.
Don't think about the elo.
Just think about the quota.
Don't think about the loss of elo.
Just think about the hours I need to stream.
That's...
That's it.
This is it.
We just...
We need to get the hours in.
Okay, are they still...
Is it still freaky hours or...
Are people actually killing?
Can I actually warm up?
Oh, that's a dead Penny body.
Yeah, people are definitely killing.
Oh my god.
I just see like a fucking fuck you all from the sky.
I don't think I've only done this map like three times.
Usually, I never go here.
What?
Wait, you guys saw that, right?
He fucking lagged.
What the fuck?
What the fuck was...
What the fuck is this brawl I'm looking at?
Oh my god.
He's scared.
Oh my...
Bro, okay.
Bro, fuck you.
No!
Okay.
Maybe I'll just play Adam.
I'm just gonna play Adam next game.
Fuck it.
I mean, that's all I need.
The moment I play Adam, it'll be okay, right?
Okay.
Goodbye, Chuck.
Goodbye.
I don't even play Hela.
What are you doing here, Mantis?
Where did the Mantis go?
What the fuck?
Yo, fuck that guy though.
Alright.
Maybe it'll be different.
There's no Celestial players now.
I just need one win.
I'm playing Adam.
Okay, this is it.
We don't have support players except for me.
Maybe I can't play Adam.
Maybe.
We don't even...
Okay.
What?
What goes through?
What the fuck is...
What?
What's going on?
Why are people mad already?
What?
What's going...
Goodbye.
He said, fuck that.
Said, fuck that game.
I can't.
Our team already throwing.
Two, three people on our team hate each other.
And we're banning their main.
Holy shit, what the fuck happened?
Four, three...
I like how Choppa was like, but winnable.
Choppa, it was not winnable.
Choppa, it was...
It was not winnable.
Stop going, why go?
Never give up.
Komas gave up.
That's actually crazy.
Never give up.
Holy shit.
That's crazy, I like Choppa.
Don't worry, Choppa.
I'm here for you, Choppa.
Go, Choppa, go.
Never give up.
Goodbye, Choppa.
We'll never know who these players were that absolutely hate.
I love this guy.
Kraken except when he's...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, guys.
Okay.
Oh, we'll never know.
It doesn't show who it was.
I don't even know who they were.
Who we had.
Let's see.
Wait, what account is he gonna be on?
Oh, never mind.
Gome has no account in range.
Duo?
Yo, he's stupid.
Okay.
Not me.
That's not true.
I saw you were 200...
200...
260...
Before I invite.
You were losing before me.
He was losing before me.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Let's...
Let's go to Celestial.
Can I...
I will make sure your main is also Celestial.
Goodbye, 500.
There we go.
I don't have keyboard left anymore.
Play with controller.
Go, go.
No keyboard left.
Shame.
Feels bad.
Free ELO night.
Maybe.
Now you are FunFun.
Nice.
The free ELO isn't going up.
Wow.
Wait, is FunFun okay?
How you know that Korean meme?
Wait, what?
It's a meme?
Where's FunFun?
Where is he?
FunFun.
Oh, no.
Is FunFun okay?
Oh, wait.
FunFun.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
FunFun129.
What happened?
FunFun...
What did he do?
FunFun not so much fun no more.
He was once a great man.
What did you do to him?
Oh, my God.
He was once a great man, guys.
Poor guy.
He's gone.
He died by his own hands.
Holy fuck.
Why didn't you save him?
You are not save team.
How could you?
He chose this.
I can't...
He is so far ahead.
I can't catch him.
It's the path he chose.
I'm so sad.
I'm so sad, guys.
I can't believe... He used to... Guys.
FunFun used to be...
He used to have 500 points, guys.
He used to have 500 points.
What?
Oh, wait.
What happened?
Oh, what?
Why?
They have Necros?
Then I'm banning.
I mean, I'd rather just...
Wait, is he playing with... Is he playing with Venom player?
I mean, fine.
I would just... I would have honestly just banned...
I would have banned Venom.
Jesus Christ.
FunFun.
I don't fucking know.
Fuck it.
He is always a pain to kill.
I was thinking about banning Venom.
I wish I banned Venom.
Fuck FunFun playing... Fuck Chopper playing Venom.
Yo.
Okay.
Why here?
I mean, I can go Adam.
I could go Adam.
If the other one wants to go Luna.
Luna?
Fuck it.
I guess I go Luna.
I guess...
Is he... He's just talking to himself.
Everybody else is just like, what the fuck?
He's just talking to himself.
They did not... They don't have Necro...
Did we just do a random Spider-Man ban for no fucking reason?
And we're running Mantis Luna without Adam?
Okay.
Why the fuck did we... Okay.
Just did a random Spider-Man for no fucking reason.
Why did we run Mantis with no Adam?
That's actually... Now we're actually throwing.
There was no reason.
There's actually no reason to...
Oh, I wanna go up.
Oh my god, I need to reload.
Oh my god, I'm trying, I'm trying, I'm reloading, I'm reloading, I'm reloading, I'm reloading, I'm reloading.
I'm reloading.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, I might as well, I might just give this to the Venom.
This is a struggle for me.
I'm just gonna give it to the Venom.
Oh my god, guys, don't see the miscast, I've been playing for too long.
Already?
Holy shit.
Hey Mantis, you can ult first.
Oh.
Okay, nevermind, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
Okay, yeah.
Okay, let's go.
Oh, don't fear.
Oh my god.
Nice.
I... what?
When did I kill him?
Okay.
They just fell into... okay, cool.
They lie.
Oh.
I was just like, what?
How did they...
I was like, how the fuck?
I didn't even know where they came from.
I was so confused.
I was like, where did he go?
Where did he come from?
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
We're okay.
Alright, we're okay.
I don't know what... I can't hear him.
I don't want to get Hanzo'd.
Oh my god.
I need to get back on the cart.
I don't want to get Hawkeye'd slash Hanzo'd.
I'm too scared.
Okay, I missed.
That's okay.
Okay.
Guys, it's okay.
I can't hit every shot, guys.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Nice, okay.
Okay.
I'm freaking out.
Top 5 ult.
Oh, nevermind.
Don't use.
Alright.
Oh.
Okay, okay.
What?
How did he get that?
Question mark?
Okay, we're doing it.
We're doing it, guys.
We're doing it.
Okay, I'm a little scared now.
I'm a little scared.
All I'm saying is that Mantis Luna should not be working, but I'll take it.
That's me.
JK, he missed?
Okay, I take those.
Okay, nice.
We take those, we take those.
We take the misses.
It's okay.
Normally, Luna Mantis should not be working because that is not a lot of heals.
But I'm not gonna question it.
I'm not gonna...
What?
That missed?
Should not have missed.
What?
What was my HP?
Okay, I think I got Hawkeye.
Yeah, I got Hawkeye headshot.
I got Hawkeye headshot.
There was no way I should have died.
Through Invisa.
I was like, what happened to me?
Actually, what happened to me?
I disappeared.
I actually disappeared.
Okay.
Oh, I don't want to stand near...
Oh, I...
I don't know what happens if I stand in front of a Hawkeye.
Yo, I think maybe...
It is Gomez.
No, I want it so bad.
He didn't drop the silver, guys.
He didn't drop the silver.
Let me say easy.
Don't talk about that, Dark.
Yeah, my ult was doki doki.
My Dark Pass.
Don't talk about...
That Dark History.
Wow.
Overwatch will never be beating Golden Age.
Jesus.
What the fuck happened to him?
Oh my...
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
What happened?
They all got deleted.
You do not need healing.
Oh, I don't want to peek that.
There's a Hawkeye right there.
I do not want to peek that.
Hello.
What is this Mag doing?
He's just chilling.
His entire team is dead.
Where are you going?
Where the fuck are you going?
Wait, I hear somebody.
Oh, he's gone.
Our poor Starlord is not having a good time.
Where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
Goodbye.
Honestly, I did not expect to hit that.
Okay.
I fucking do not want to look at the Hawkeye.
If I see a Hawkeye in front of me, I leave.
Oh, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
Where did I go?
Hello?
No, no!
Oh wait, it's okay.
Please!
I just got home!
What?
I died.
Bye, Panther.
Okay, nice.
Thank you.
Thank you, bodyguard.
It's okay.
We're alive.
Wakanda forever.
Wait, I hear it back.
Black Panther behind us.
Oh my god.
Not again!
Never again!
That was a heal diff.
We have Mantis!
How could it ever be a heal diff?
We have significantly less heals.
I am not...
I will not dealing with this again.
You can't get me.
Oh, three, two, one.
It's okay.
It's okay, everything's fine.
Everything is fine.
Okay, he's coming over.
He's coming!
Please!
Please, Mantis!
I need one E!
One E and everything will be okay!
One E!
Please!
Just one little E!
If I get one E, I can live!
That's all it takes!
I know it's actually crazy to think about.
Bro, this is rage, babe.
What's going on?
Ah!
I'm getting cyberbullied!
Somebody get me out of here!
I'm actually getting cyberbullied on stream!
Like, why is it me?
Why is it me?
I don't...
I don't understand!
Oh, no.
Please.
I'm just behind.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry!
I don't want to deal with this!
I needed the Mantis to know what it feels like!
I needed...
Oh my god!
Okay, now the Mantis knows what it felt like!
Now he knows!
Now he fucking knows!
I was not... I wasn't gonna save... I wasn't gonna try and save our Mantis with the ult.
I needed him to know what it felt like there.
It's karma.
It's actual karma.
Oh my god, he didn't hit that?
I'm surprised he didn't hit that.
No, no, don't get me!
He ran the same way as me!
I thought he would run the opposite way.
Why did he follow me?
Why did I get... I chose that path first!
I was there first!
What the fuck do you mean?
I chose that path first!
Maybe it wasn't going...
I hear him.
I hear him!
Guys, I hear him!
Don't...
Oh, please...
PLEASE!
Mantis!
I need one macro!
Please!
Please, Mantis!
Please, just give me one E!
Please!
It's all I want in life.
Oh my God!
The only way to live!
Oh my...
This is the only way to live.
Oh my God, we make history!
We did it!
Okay, but should we try winning as a trio though?
He wants to come back.
Do we let him back in?
Google him.
Google him!
Yeah, Google him!
Gomez body monkey.
Do we get him?
Wait...
No, Gomez!
Where is he?
Is he banned?
Okay...
Where is he?
Wait, he got off!
Yo...
What a...
Keep this...
Okay!
He got kicked out!
Yo, okay...
I'm just playing.
Okay, I'm telling it, Gomez.
Get used to it.
He got voted off the island!
Nah...
How's Adobe doing?
Okay, what if...
Okay, I know I said...
What if we...
Last game if we win?
But like, what if we win as a stack though?
What if we...
Don't...
Yo, don't call the Adobe!
But why...
What happened...
To the Adobe?
Where is he?
This place, huh?
What did he do?
Think of the quota, you're right!
Think of the quota!
Think of...
There you go.
Choppa said you suck, Gomez.
Liar!
Dude...
You fake!
Thank you guys.
Thank you for the partner anniversary, everybody.
I really appreciate it.
Yeah.
Go, go.
Did...
Did you cry?
How did it feel...
When you saw us...
Saw us win?
He was in the corner.
Damn.
This is not my fault.
This is all Potty's fault.
Guys...
It's not my fault, guys.
It's all...
It's not my fault.
I'm badass.
Exactly.
I was winning, guys.
I was winning.
It's okay.
We're doing better.
It's getting...
Things do get better, guys.
It gets better.
It really does.
I am the example.
Things do get better.
Things might be tough back then.
But...
It's gonna turn around.
See?
No.
Choppa is cooler.
And better.
You just right.
Yeah, my five sleeps made him come back.
Made him...
Let me kidnap him.
Tell the police...
Okay, what if I can play Adam now?
I'm gonna do it.
It's gonna work this time.
I did win on Luna, though.
I don't know why.
Whenever I stream...
Oh, nice.
They also are going through Venom PTSD.
Thank fucking God.
I'm glad that...
I'm glad that they're going through Venom PTSD as well.
I'm...
Oh, that makes me so happy.
He did it!
Choppa finally did it!
He's not Venom noob anymore.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Choppa, it's time.
Choppa, mercy.
Play...
Play mercy.
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
Choppa, no play mercy.
Choppa, dang.
And I skipped it.
Thank you for getting two tier one subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
If Adam doesn't work, I'll swap.
Thanks, number three.
I do my best.
It can't be that bad, guys.
Life can't be that bad.
I have 16 days.
16 days.
I have to do the stacking thing again soon, guys.
Oh.
Chichi, go next.
Okay.
If we lose, it's all on me.
All good.
Five.
Oh, it's totally five.
Wait.
I hear a flanking Jeff.
Flanking Jeff?
I need to reload.
Goodbye, clone.
Goodbye.
There's a Jeff behind us.
Oh my god.
I don't have heals left.
Save him.
I'm at zero heals.
Please.
I can't offer anymore.
Oh, I can.
I'm still at zero though.
Oh my god.
You're so bun.
I feel so weak.
No soulbond.
Nice.
What the fuck?
Where did he come from?
Okay, nice.
We're doing it!
Yes!
Oh, fuck!
It's okay.
I have no more heals now.
I can be reserved with these.
Get out of here.
Don't worry.
My soulbond will last throughout this.
Oh my god.
I got swallowed.
Goodbye.
Oh, please.
I don't...
Oh no.
That's unlucky.
TP, TP, TP.
I saw, I saw.
Okay, I'm going to walk over.
I have rez.
It's fine.
Everybody is okay.
Okay.
Wait, what the fuck?
There's a hell of a buff.
Oh my god.
Guys, his AD was just too good.
Okay?
His AD was too good, guys.
Like, I don't know what you want me to do.
Guys, please.
I'm heading there as soon as I can.
I'm on the point.
The best I could.
Nice.
It's okay.
Okay.
Don't shield.
Please.
I'm so fun.
Here.
Two seconds, two seconds.
Okay, there we go.
No problem, no problem, no problem.
There we go.
We're not finished yet.
Oh my god.
Yuzu, thank you for the...
Thank you for the 70.
Thank you for the raid.
I really appreciate it.
For those who don't know me, my name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube, but now I'm here on Twitch because I have a partnership with Rivals.
I'm out of quota of hours.
So that's why I'm here.
It's okay, we're losing.
It's all about the quota.
It's all about the quota, guys.
Money over rank elo.
Oh, but the badge is so shiny.
Oh, but the badge.
Okay, we'll fix it.
We'll fix our elo off stream.
We can fix it off stream.
Of course, of course, of course.
Here for that congratulatory content.
But it's shiny!
Alright.
Hold on.
I need Mantis, Mantis real quick.
Okay.
Oh my god, and I hit a headshot.
Okay, that was useless.
That was useless.
There's a clown.
Okay.
So he was throwing.
He was throwing.
Oh my god!
You're fucking welcome!
Please, please, please.
What is this?
I swear to god, if you do not kill him, I swear to god.
Thank god, okay.
I'm fucking TPing here.
Get these clones out of here.
There's a Jeff up there.
Wait, Jeff's on me.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, oh, two portals.
No lamp.
Anyways.
Oh, fuck you.
Wait, how did he get back?
That's right.
Fuck you.
Oh my god!
We did it!
Monkey's back.
I'm not a problem.
He's not the problem!
Okay, that my LG.
GG's.
Party.
Monkey.
That's my LG.
We did it!
We did it, guys!
I sleep.
It's 5am!
I can't keep going!
GG.
Don't drop like FunFun.
GG's, everyone.
We are not the problem.
Look, we did it, guys.
We weren't the problem.
See?
We can win!
Guys!
I'm not pulling up my history.
I'm not.
I'm only down...
6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
I'm down 3 games, technically.
I rounded down.
I'm down 3 games.
But I'm not...
We're not the problem.
It's...
It's fine.
We're just...
We're just down...
We're down 3 games.
No, we're not showing...
Okay, anyway.
Thank you, everybody, for watching.
I hope you guys had...
I'm not...
It's 5 in the morning and I need to walk my dog.
Anyway.
I had a great time today.
I might stream again tomorrow.
Because I just want to make...
I want to see if I can get the quota in within this week.
So I don't have to worry about next week.
But anyway, guys.
Thank you all for coming.
For those who are new here, my name is DokiBird.
I usually stream on YouTube.
So please check me out there.
You can do exclamation point socials or exclamation point...
I think it's YouTube.
I don't know.
If you guys want to know whenever I stream on Twitch, please follow me on Twitter.
Because I usually tweet out whenever I stream on Twitch.
So follow me on Twitter there.
And if you guys want to support me on other means, I do have a couple of merch stuff that's being sold right now.
Including some plushies.
Some official plushies.
So exclamation point...
What was it?
Plush.
If you want to...
Exclamation point plush.
If you want to grab some official DokiBird merch.
Right there.
Wait.
Let me see if I can...
Where's the picture of it?
Live now.
Yes.
So I do have official plushies that you can buy right now.
If you guys want to support me via other means, it really does help out a lot.
Hey, guys.
I'm going to head off now.
As always, everybody.
Thank you for all the bitties.
For all the subs.
For all the follows.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pause your check.
Grab and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you want...
Sorry.
What was it?
My brain freezed there.
Too many rivals.
And if you stayed up for me, head to...
Sorry, I stumbled.
Stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.